Bob auditing, leaning. Dong,
Dong Ding Dong. Ding, Ding Dong.
Ding Dong.
Ding Dong Ding Ding Dong
does that. The intro auditing,
Dong Ding Dong gum kind
of fucking intro is that,
but I didn't think being being done,
this is how relaxed they are.
One year in. We have no idea
what's going on. Like wait,
was that an intro just starts.
We've got to stop using music folks for
legal purposes and all sorts of other
shit. But when I got sued,
so that's our music. Oh,
what was that song I
sing? I don't know. Yeah,
we said copyright that sued them and
they want to use it as fucking horse.
We'll call it. Welcome to the podcast
pitches. Ladies and gentlemen,
the one and only Ms. Dot. Ari Shaffir
is joining us today. Thank you.
Thank you very much.
Appreciate it.
Ari would be here to promote
his shows in San Francisco,
but unfortunately for cunts,
they're all sold out. Sold out. I'm,
I'm super happy about it.
He's balling storyteller shows.
So you going to promote subway instead?
Sandwiches.
So where are these shows at?
So people know where they
can't go. The purple onion,
they might release them
that they have to show up.
I don't really understand how that works.
Well,
what happens is sometimes people reserve
them and they don't pick them up and
they don't pay for him and they flake,
which I'm sure happens at time,
especially in San Francisco. He fuck it,
flaky free. I buy second sentence raining.
It's like, no, I'm not going
anywhere. People just flake, dude.
There's a certain amount of
people that always flake.
No matter how bad ass the concert is,
pink Floyd's the wall,
whatever the fuck it is.
I think it was just going to flake.
There's a certain amount.
You just have to accept that if friend
just had a birthday party and she was
pissed because more people said they
were going to show up and do it,
and I was like, Oh, you've never tried
to promote a show, nobody comes. Yeah.
And that's, that's ridiculous.
Have unreasonable expectations.
The worst is when you buy tickets and
then you break up at the girl and then
you're like,
ah,
I don't want to see fucking
whoever block Morrissey and to uh,
to Coachella. Well, first of all,
you're dating some depressing bitches.
If they want to go see Morrison,
we might've found a problem.
Morrissey, man, if you ever wanted
to cry, Mexicans are under them.
Them to and to Morris Morris in this mess.
I have no idea why Mexicans
are super into Morrissey. Wow.
Maybe Mexicans totally wished they
were whiny white people, right?
Of a Mexican Sarah into
flashlights. Oh, that's right.
We're sponsored by the flashlight.
Flashlight. Doctor Suck. The subtle segue,
if you go Joe rogan.net,
there's a link for a flashlight and click
the link and enter in a the word rogue
and you get 15% off.
We're just trying to save you money.
Bitches are just trying to save
people money on flushed lights.
I don't want any buddy beaten off for
retail. Just don't think that's right
at his girl. Find my flesh language. Do
you really use this? And I'm like, yeah,
yeah, you want to watch? And she's just
starts putting her fingers. And I'm like,
you do know. I just said I, you could use
it. She gets, I don't care. You washed it,
right? I'm like, yeah, I guess.
How often do you not wash it?
This is the girl you were
boning. Uh Huh. No, just uh,
please touch her house or boning. Yeah.
You're trying to vote on them? No, no,
it's just my landlord. Oh, you're Atlanta
was not playing with their fleshlight.
Brian story is full of holes.
I was coming up short
last month in rent and
feed off into the fleshlight
for, no, not that. Nothing.
It's like the scene
when he's hurling,
he's a toilet and she's talking
about something, but you know, fuck.
It makes you really want to take a shit.
I love that.
I want to see you hit their new movie and
they have a new movie coming out where
it's like about this guy that's married
and he gets to take a week off of the
marriage or something like that. Oh, it
was from the same guys I believe. Yeah.
Yeah. They made some great shit. They
made something about Mary too. Yeah,
I read this book. It was about
being a comic. Oh really?
About stand up? I think so.
If I remember just living in like
no apartment with his brother.
I believed it been doing comedy.
I remember
it's been so long. They're
east coast guys. The comedy
writer is what it's called.
Do you got? Oh yeah. You've got
to wash. Speaking of comedy,
got to watch Denis Leary's new
comedy central special. Oh is it?
Must be that good. Wow. You're like,
like didn't talk down to you like an
actor who's never really done standup,
has to write his own material
and then play a standup in
a movie. No, really just,
is it just rusty? It's just death.
There's just nothing funny there.
It's just a missing. What's funny, would
you ever have him on the podcast? A No,
because I don't want them over my
house and I would probably want to,
you could always go to the desk squad to,
he's the type of guy that would be like
kind of threatened you and for talking
the truth. He's not a good
guy, you know, the, the whole,
the whole scene is just
ugly. But it was fascinating
watching it. You know, I, I've,
I root for people, man. I
wanted it to be good. You know,
I would not get a work out and stuff
beforehand. He's not in the same guy.
He live in la? Yeah, I think so. I Dunno.
I've never heard of been
working on is actually,
I think he lives in the east coast. Okay.
I root for him, man. I swear to God,
I root for everybody would be better and
root for everybody to to get over their
bullshit. You know everybody
that's done shady shit in the past.
If you even, you got to feel that this
is shady. I root for, I swear to God,
but fuck, fuck. It was just a void.
It was a void. Know here's my
favorite comic. When I first started,
when I was an open microphone,
like six months. Who's my
favorite comic? Really? Oh,
he was just killer.
He was just Troyer and like so much more
aggressive than anybody
I've ever seen on stage.
So much more like my kind of comedy
and like the type of people that I was
hanging around with and like the,
the shit that I was used to, I was,
he's the hard people.
You know,
like the comedy that I was used to is
all from mostly from boxing gems from my,
my, my boxing coach, Joe Lake,
the guy who had his finger bitten off
a street fight and had a toe attached
where his finger was and
curled permanently so he
could keep throwing right
hooks. Not Kidding. He had his
stroke. I had my belt put curled.
I had it done like this, so I could
fucking told her. Right. Yeah, he's crazy.
He was on he,
he's far fucking animal.
I don't want to tell all the stories
that I know because I don't know what he
wants to get out there on the Internet,
but these are the type of people I was
hanging out with forms that kind of
surgery. There's bedroom, there's,
did they do that finger back and he
told the doctor what Craig or Dr Bunch,
you know, he didn't want a straight
finger. That would be terrible.
It gets stuck in the boxing
glove because I couldn't move.
He couldn't articulate the finger
anymore because the nerves are gone. Oh,
they're all separate.
Somebody bit his fucking
finger off and it's true. Ah,
how does it get to that move?
Like at what point are you losing
my friend Mike [inaudible] time?
My friend Mike Blight was a bouncer at
the rathskeller and he was a professional
boxer and he wasn't,
I mean he would drink occasionally,
but we wasn't drinking when he was
there and he didn't look like a killer.
He looks like a very, he's a very smart
guy too. And he's very well spoken,
but he's a straight south Boston
thug and he worked glasses and ship.
He's a pro boxer and so he would just
totally get off on just lighting up drunk
college dudes,
you know,
guides who would get stupid and guys that
would get in his face and got and who
would allow them to like literally almost
pick on him before he would knock them
unconscious. Yeah, it just, he would
say, I'm a, I'm telling you this is,
you guys are making a big mistake.
You know, this is not the way to go.
I don't know.
I don't know how you're living your life.
And then he would just turn
on them whether you fucking
figure you fucking pussy.
Oh really? Oh, what, what the bank,
it would just just tee off on him.
He's a pro boxer who's fucking good ones.
And then all their friends to be like,
you got to knock out by a nerd. No, he
was, he would knock them out. So scary.
They would all just slack jaw and
wait for their animals, their animals.
Nuke that whole era of us,
I should knock it out and it's lost
is the craziest place I've ever been.
I've never,
I mean in what I do shows there,
like the last time I did a show there at
that, uh, that, that theater and the, the,
the what used to be the combat zone,
I forgot the name of the theater.
10 action come. It used to be the
common connection. Now it's a theater.
The Wilbur, the Willard here. It's
a beautiful theater. That was cool.
I forgot that. But you realize they're
savages. They're just wild. Or people,
you know, they're more willing to
fight. They're, they're more than,
am I going to have complained about shit,
they're less likely to deal with
bullshit. Take your shit. You know,
they're less likely to let
you get away with anything.
Like there's certain shit that people
get away with in California that I didn't
realize like when I came out
here that people lived like this,
that like act or talk, you know,
like, you know when you eat here,
people talking on the sad
and just straight actor
talking. No one ever calls them on
their bullshit and it's like, Ooh,
when did you start sounding
like that in Boston?
Everybody calls everybody on everything.
You don't ever get to put on airs.
There's so many fights,
but it's also why there's so many
comedians come from that area.
So many comics came from that spot, man.
Whenever it happened to Dave Moore, Dell,
I was thinking about him the other day.
Is He still doing stand up? He's what?
A show for awhile. Yeah. Funny.
Had some sort of a comic standing for a
little bit, right? Yeah. Good comment.
A man. He's hilarious. I got
to work with him in New York.
I did a show with him in New
York. He's really funny, man.
He's, uh, he's, yeah, he's,
he's like real, like solid
professional, you know, really
good timing. Good writing,
good writing. What happened
man? Yeah, there was a,
I did stand up last night and it was
an actress that was doing the, yeah,
she was on the phone and she says
like, yeah, I'm doing standup tonight.
It's my first time.
It's going to be easy.
He was doing it while she's
gonna be so easy. Actually,
I had just paid $15 and what it is,
it's like 10 people go up in the audience
votes and I'm going to fucking take
this. It's, I mean it's,
this is gonna be like,
it's just never talking shit
about how easy it's going to be.
I wanted to stay,
but that would be the worst comedy ever,
so I'm not going to ever watch
that. Yeah, that's fascinating.
Know every talk you see someone you've
never done, you're going to be awesome.
Especially something that hard.
Never done it jack.
The owner was just out back around.
They're just like, just cleaning at her,
you know,
like just laughing his ass off.
There's people that think they're going
to be awesome at everything before they
ever do it.
Those are the Douche bags of the world
because they've never really tested
themselves and develop character where
character comes from its failure and
recognizing and being humble and you
know and feeling the humility and knowing
that, okay, you know what man that
no one's perfect. This is crazy.
Like all my Hubris of youth,
that's all it a logical and
it doesn't make any sense,
but the people that keep it like forever
and they have it in their thirties and
shit and forties and they just,
they think they could do anything.
Richard Taylor of the old manager
of the Congress remember? Yeah,
at 39 he thought he could still play
on some teams in the NFL and start a
quarterback. I still got an arm for
real. I've walked with be an all pro,
but I can beat song guys out. We're like
how cocky you have to be first of all,
no, you've never been anything. Second
of all, you're 39 even if you were great,
you still can't compete.
Now,
the only guys who can keep competing
like when they're in their late thirties
and forties and shit like the first
of all, it's very, very recent.
So you have to start
thinking about chemicals.
You have to start thinking about chemicals
because we all want to think that
everybody's doing everybody's
natural and just doing squats.
And I don't want to
cast judgment on anyone,
but when you look at like
40 year old athletes,
there was no bread farms when I was a kid,
they didn't exist.
There's no 40 year old dudes
playing professional football.
What in the Super Bowl
are you shitting me?
That guy's got gray hair listening.
Even register
like Bernard Hopkins, there's never
been someone like Bernard Hopkins.
See George Foreman when he won the title.
He was 46 years old when he knocked out
Michael Moore, but well that's kind of,
he was getting his fucking ass kick
before that and he hit him with like some
legit old man strength.
You know what I mean?
Like the George Foreman was
just an old strong tough dude.
He never looked dug a young
guy when he was older,
he looked like a big ass strong
old dude that could fuck you up.
And he worked out real hard.
You would push trucks and shit in his
driveway and he was like one of the
pioneers of like chopping logs.
That was all like old, old,
old school training shit. Back in the
Joe Lewis days, he brought it all back.
But if you look at like Bernard Hopkins,
he's 46 man and he looks like he's
30 it's the craziest thing ever.
There's never been a professional boxer.
I don't know. I can't, I can't say.
But you're saying it's weird.
It's fucking beyond weird.
It doesn't make any sense. It's never
existed before. Sugar Ray Leonard,
when he got to his like late thirties
it was a rap. You know everybody else.
It's a wrap.
Bernard Hopkins 46 not even 41 that
even 40 almost 46 and he's out in super
athletes. That means,
what's the formatting like
defendants title a few times.
Yeah. Yeah. No, he really fought
Tommy Marsy law said to Toni Morrison.
So did he defend it?
He might not have defended it.
He knocked out my horse was a champion.
Tommy Morrison had some
wacky belt. He won, uh,
from George Foreman.
He beat George Foreman.
I thought it was just a
contender when he got, no,
I'm pretty sure Tommy Marson
won the title. I'm pretty sure.
I know he'd beat George Foreman
decision. What were those belts
that used to tie in and you're like,
fold it around and then back of
like as London fog coats, the belts,
belts were on level. Fuck what
are no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
They were like the leather belts that
like were really long and then you had to
like kind of twirl it around.
Oh, you got it on right now.
Yeah. Except this isn't that
long. It's been that long.
Wow. Yeah. I'm wearing it. I'm
what citizen if becomes psychically
more vacated. The title. That's bizarre.
I don't even understand that. That's
still where we're in the vacate a title,
not retirement. I mean like I
threw in the garbage can. Yeah.
You know what the problem with
boxing for real, super crooked.
It's not just super crooked.
There's so many organizations,
there's not just one
UFC style organization.
You know a lot of people bitch about
UFC beam and beat in a monopoly.
But at least you know
when you have a monopoly,
at least you got white
one clear world champion.
There's a Wbo, the IBF, the WBA,
the WBC,
and a bunch of other ones that people
weren't sure whether they should take
seriously.
Like there's a gang of the world champ
and say somebody retires and make the
belts open. It's like, well, who do we
think is the most deserving of it? Yeah,
they do that.
They make guys fight,
but they all make a decision on their own.
Who would she be? Yeah, exactly. It's,
I mean, that's how it is with the UFC and
strike force too, because now we have,
you know, strike forces,
this big heavyweight
tournament that's coming up and they have
failed over and over and we got a lot
of good guys in their tournament, man.
But it's, it's almost kind of annoying.
You know, it's like, man, I want
to see everyone fight everyone.
I want it to be one big giant league.
There's gotta be a way they can do that.
They're pushing for that in baseball to
have a Japanese versus American world
champion really are we're real
world or real world champion.
That would be the shit that would be
the one that would be dope. You know,
it'd be dope.
I hate to say it,
but I would love if Japanese dudes
came over here at kicked Americans,
ask his son of a bitch, son of a
bitch, communists tug. There you,
there should be a,
where were you?
The problem is no one's going
to be willing to do that.
I was going to say with
UFC and strike force,
no one's going to be willing to say,
you know,
then the guy rep or whoever the champion
as he represents your organization and
you know each guy fight it
out for each weight class.
Like that's like too much of a downside,
you know? Then if you lose, you get that.
You get our champions.
And what if the UFC got all the
champions then strike force.
What they just go out of business
then, you know, if that gets tricky,
what are they going to, they can't
have, it was just an new champion.
I have a title. You can't have a
title, you know, but it's weird.
You know you got nick Diaz is a champion
over there and George St Pierre was a
champion over here.
But I guess what?
They're not fighting as long as they
keep Nick Diaz happy and they keep paying
them, you know, they're not
going to fight. Keep smoking.
I was right in a way that 10 whites,
a little wary of him too because he uh,
he got in a fight with Joe rigs in
the hospital after they were Africans.
They argued when they were in the
hospital and Nikki has jumped him in the
hospital. They had IV bags on and shit
and he's beating his ass in the hospital.
Stockton guys out of their minds. It,
him, him and his brother are there.
Look how those guys are the real deal.
They're not fucking around.
Don't talk shit unless you want.
You get your plan, your face bunch.
We hung out in Stockton and we hung up
that there was this chick at some bar
were there and we had like a 45
minute drive to get back home.
And the young guy and the tour
and the monsters store was like,
we were trying to get him some, the girl
was like intuit, right? So he was like,
I don't know if I can get it.
We were like, Hey, come on,
you're gonna come back with us and shit.
I was like, can you get back tomorrow?
She goes, yeah, I'll find a ride. She
just is weird girl at the bar. Let's go.
You're coming. Let's go. So we got in the
backseat and then he got really cold. Um,
uh, she started rapping. Yeah,
she started rapping randomly.
He got really cold to where he goes, oh,
I don't want to, I'm like, why? He goes,
she told me she was autistic and I was
like, what? I'm like, all right. Behavior.
It makes complete sense now.
I just thought she was weird and quirky.
So autistic people are well aware
that they have an issue. Yeah.
And she was doing tons of blow.
Oh my God,
that sounds so owning it and
then rapping 30 straight minutes,
autistic and low and she's a
wigger. I drove her back to her. Um,
I'm assuming it's not a black rooms
at a black or white girl and what she
rapping like a black girl. Yeah. Nice.
That's what I assumed. All those things.
It's kind of a painted for myself
because that would be the most,
this something very special about poor
white people that act like poor black
people.
There's a weirdness to it man.
Serious when like white dudes are like
real serious about being street and
acting pill. But like is it just a
poor thing? No, no, not necessarily.
I mean a little bit of it.
Sure. I mean cause their
world interacts, you know that they're
intertwined in other communities.
The poor white and poor black communities.
I mean poor people have to live
where poor people live. And I'm like,
and I lived in Jamaica Plain.
There was a lot of poor white people
and poor black people together.
But it's just some weird,
when a dude has a clear affectation,
just takes it on and all sudden, you know,
it's like he won't get crazy, you know,
you won't get crazy.
And yet like I've seen white guys talk
like that and you're like, wow, okay.
There's no part of the country
where white people talk like that.
You didn't see that on TV if this isn't
like a rural Greensboro South Carolina
thing and like, well everybody
has his weird accent there.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no. You're clearly urban, black,
urban, black southern a little bit,
you know, and then the, and due
to New York do it too. A lot of,
a lot of white and from the north then.
Okay. Yeah. Still talking like a southern.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Two Guy. I've seen
guys do it, especially back in the, um,
in the 90s,
there was a lot of guys that would a
especially involved in like when I was
playing pool and I was going and
watching guys gamble on pool,
there was always a lot of like these sort
of thug type characters who were white
guys that talked like black
guys that would even say nigger.
They would say like this isn't a thing.
You've got to come here and
take all that shit. You're like,
what's this Nigga think he going
to come here and take out La Shit.
Shut this motherfucker who's up.
Shoulders are going to be like, wow,
like this guys.
It's like an alien personally.
You're near not just saying these things.
You think then that
guy's saying that line.
Do you think he still feels
it when he says the n word?
You think he's still in charge at all?
He's squirming a little and let,
I mean he must be on
Oxycontin's if he's hot,
you know you're a white guy and you're,
you're saying nigger and especially
he's got like, he had like, you know,
like a really shit short shaved head.
Like almost like,
like a almost like a skinhead but like
little stubble on his head, you know,
so it's like you were,
you were just so much whiteness.
There's whiteness everywhere.
There's whiteness all over your head.
You don't even have like
a bunch of black hair.
I look at you and it's curly
hair and I'm like, man,
this guy's like part black or
something. No, no, nothing.
He was like super white and I met Jason
Kidd and he's doing these things with
his fingers, you know, were
guys like shake their hand
in the air where they talk.
There's some weird thing like that
when they hold their hand approximately
forehead level and then they just
shake it up and down like Paul,
like knuckles out and certainly they
shake their hand up and down. Yeah,
it is almost like that. It's like a chip
dad. His arms up in it's just progressed.
Do you think there are
black eyes like deep,
deep in the hood who talks super
upscale white? Yes, for sure. Yeah.
There's a lot of black guys that would
die to be white and a lot of white guys
that would be die to be black.
The most people in this world
do not want to be who they are.
I feel like everyone else has
it so much easier. Cooler.
We will let the easiness
as an insult like, oh,
your parents paid your worth
through college. I know you're like,
my parents worked hard to put me
through college. Yeah. Is that bad?
The people want us to leave.
Everyone wanted me to be smoking.
Having it harder as the way
cooler way to be. Why? Yeah,
you didn't get there for real.
You ain't legit.
You ain't just treat so it's like a
stock and guys stuck with it for real.
It's like even move he there.
He gets a crazy place to live.
You want to live where you can go to
sleep and not worrying about fucking
gunshots coming through your window.
It's nice.
It's one thing you might be into
something like that idea of thrills out of
nowhere.
Some people like like living in Silver
Lake and hearing sirens all the time.
You know,
there's people that like that they feel
like they're in the heart of some sort
of an artist's colony.
Arrieta's yeah,
I drove use of Homea Dave Silver Lake
and there's some of those streets that
look like straight Gatto yeah,
just straight like what Rick talks walking
over across the street with no tags
at all. Pitbulls yeah,
several weeks. Tricky man.
It's cause you got a bunch of hipsters
and they're living with a bunch of gang
bangers, you know? And I think a lot of
them must get robbed, right? Don't they?
Probably.
You've got to have bars.
I always worried about Dunkin Cause
Dunkin is like super into like living in
those kind of areas. He lives in
that was anyone even broken into any,
but he's like the first guy to wet
his pants. If someone, you know,
he's never been broken. It's pretty
crazy. The history of his theory.
What's the neighborhood?
Yeah,
what's some famous guy that bad day?
I can't really tell the story.
It's pretty famous.
I don't know if he's talked about it
and I know he has and he doesn't want
anybody to know where he lives.
I just saw that with his girl now and
I just saw that documentary. That guy,
that Guy Jim Jeff. Well, I'll tell you
after the show show's over, you know,
you really can't say because it will,
everyone will know exactly where he lives.
He lives in a weird house.
It's a long story. You know
that it got a Kool aid guy.
Jim Jeffries. Is that his name was Jim
Jefferies. Yeah. Yeah. No, no, no, no.
You're talking about the comedian? No,
no, no. The guy that got Yana trategy,
Jim Jones,
Jim Jones.
I was watching the documentary about that
the other day and it mixes the ido in
with the video and stuff with Gabby.
You guys seen this documentary?
I highly recommend it.
I think it was on Netflix or something
like that and it showed videos and it
talked to the guy's brother the
whole time. He's like, yeah,
my brother then told everybody to,
you know, drink this and do that. No,
it wasn't even cooler. Those poor
Koolaid fucks. Right. It was like,
couldn't even get grape drink.
Right. There's like some drink. Yeah.
And they were showing up there was
shooting it in the kid's mouth with like
tricky based or type things. Oh
my God. And yeah, and the niche.
I didn't know how many people
also died from like NBC News,
a senator or it was a senator
died. All the got there. Got
Shot. Killed, right? Yeah,
yeah. They murdered them. A senator. We
landed there. Yeah, a bunch of people.
Well it got real tricky because you know,
there was a lot of them and this guys,
they basically were running sort
of a paramilitary operation.
You had guns and shit and
then guards and you know,
whenever you get control
of a group of people,
the government is not going to let that
happen. You get, you get a big group.
Like what they tried to do in Waco,
they had themselves fenced in and they
basically started their own country.
They started real a mini country and
this we're going to talk to them and they
just went in after him. The
pro, they killed everybody.
If you go look at rules of engagement,
it's a documentary about the Waco tragedy
where they just clearly show tanks
blowing fire into buildings,
tanks or knocking over buildings and
blowing fire and the billings like a bunch
of children and women died in
this thing. He just, the dude,
they sh apparently shots were exchanged,
a few agents got hit and you know, and
there's, there's video agents like getting
shot at and shooting people and jumping
into buildings and shit and breaking
into windows and one and one
agent actually almost got
shot and so friendly fire,
use a video, you could watch it that
where a guy, you know, it's craziness.
They're breaking into windows
and shit and trying to get,
but at a certain point in time they got
the go ahead use the tanks and so they
are knocking over fucking buildings with
these tanks and you see there these see
the the gun, you know the,
what is the gun turret?
What does that part of the tank called?
It's all going to turn to the barrel
of the big long thing that looks at the
bone Hakan death.
It cock the cock of death is spraying
fire into these buildings. Dude.
It's gnarly.
Gnarly.
It's pretty gnarly because
I mean it's clear cut,
absolute unequivocal
unequivocable evidence evidence
that that fire was not an
accidental fire that plays out.
That's how I remember they
said it just caught fire.
That's when we met up a tank or something.
I mean,
unless all this is completely fake
footage. I mean I wasn't there.
I don't know for sure,
but it seems like that's what they did.
I mean all those people
died and burned to death,
but it is fire happen all the time.
How does fire happened?
Just all of a sudden your
house caught fire. Sorry. Oops.
How rare is it that fucking,
you know your got gigantic
compound with filled with bullets.
It's been around forever.
Yeah. Where is it? Where is it?
That shit just catches fire,
you know,
and there's videos of these tanks
knocking over buildings, blowing fire.
You can't be shooting at the government
are the, they're Ruby Ridge Shit.
Same Shit.
They're gonna kill you man.
I was in his room when that happened
and I remember my uncle and I asked him,
he looks, what's up with that?
What are the, I was like,
I don't know, weird thing.
I'm 18 I don't know anything
you're supposed to know. Yeah.
It represent your country. You're
not allowed to do that, man.
You're not allowed to start your
own country inside our country.
You can't just put up a fence and have
a military vehicles and everyone's got,
got like guns out in the open.
They would walk around with
like guns out rifles and shit.
Nino because stock pile of weapons.
They were just letting everybody know
that they're are protected and that this
is, you know, this is an arm
community and this one guy,
he's just banging everybody's wife. One
guy who was, that's what it was all about.
This one guy who would like play songs
and it was to play the guitar and play
music and he, he fucked everyone's wife
like a different battle star Galactica.
He, it was basically a real sick,
real similar that Balt is our guys.
Is that what his name was? Who was
his name? The the dark haired guy.
I'm making it up his name.
I might've made up his name.
I forget what the British guy, yeah, the
British guy was the real swarming guy,
but this guy was a little bit more Jesus,
like he was a little bit more, you know,
Christ like, and he
just fucking, everybody,
just a brilliant guy who realized that
he can manipulate people and he got a
bunch of Dell people that were looking
to find the way and he brought them all
together and gave Balsam
Dick. Oh, of course you want
to fuck. That's what he did.
Talk to my, you want to fuck him?
It's just, it's a tricky thing, man.
Where the government says, no, no,
no, no. You can't run that hustle,
but what about your hustle?
What about your crazy taxes
and the Federal Reserve?
Not really even being a
federal institution and all
privately owned and banks
that control everything and Bilderberg
group. What about your fucking hustle?
All this guy's doing
is getting some pussy.
You know your hustling sees a lot
worse than what they're doing. Oh,
is it was just the guns. Was that, why are
where they would want to do that? Yeah,
because he's not for the guns and let
them go ahead and do whatever. He got big.
It got the compound was, you know,
it was, they had resources, you know,
people would leave the
compound and come back.
They would work in town and come back to
the compound. It was like, it got tricky.
It got to the point where, you know, hey,
if they decided to just
take over this community,
who's going to be able to
stop them? You know, do,
do we have to protect ourselves from
this like armed group? It gets tricky.
I don't know what the exact,
you know what, what they used.
I think probably they
probably use like child abuse,
which may or may not have been true
because it's cool or something.
That could have been that.
It could have been sexual abuse.
It could have been any, I mean it might
have been true. I mean my own teasing.
I'm not saying that this
guy for sure you know,
was a great guy and the government
should have left them alone, you know?
But if we're really going to
go after people for child,
why the fuck are we not going after
the Catholic Church? Why is that not?
Why aren't they arresting the pope?
Why are they not going in to like guns
drawn to these organizations to finding
out, okay, how many of you have fuck
kids? How many of you are fucking kids?
There was a document that got released
that we were talking about before the
podcast started from 1997 that said,
the Vatican sent a letter out telling
these churches to not report cases of
child abuse to the police.
That is some nasty shit, man.
I mean if that was the case was like
anyone who covered up and didn't report it
when they knew it, like they should be
arrested. Yeah. They'll be like, hey,
you can't, you can't do that. You can't
give up stuff like that. Exactly. Anyway,
if it was anywhere else, if it was, if it
was like, you know, any other business,
any other,
exactly.
Let me tell my boss and then I
won't say anything to the place.
Let me ask my boss when he wants
to do and the boss like, no, no,
you can't just check it out loud.
If your boss is business was fucking kids,
like that was their number one hobby.
We're going to go play
golf and they would say,
go play golf with the finger quotes in
the air and that meant they were going to
go bang kids. I mean that's
really almost what it's like.
It seems for some of these,
these priests, if you watch that,
there's a terrible
documentary about a guy,
but he shipped them all over the place.
Uh,
I think it's called deliver us from evil.
Let me tell you exactly what it's called.
I like coloring and I
like watching cartoons.
I'm starting to think my age group
is a kid. Deliver us from evil.
That's what it is.
It was that it don't watch it if you
don't want to get depressed because if you
want to get depressed it will
get you depressed. It's fucking,
it's gnarly shit man. You
know, you find out like their,
their strategy of like keeping these
guys from getting in trouble and how they
could just move them instead of
like strategy talk written out man.
They're good. Praise. Let's, let's uh,
yeah, let's just try to move around.
That's what rats,
the new guy.
What does the name Raskin or what the
fuck is his name? Poke poke county. Fuck.
The fifth where a former Nazi. Yeah, the
creepy guy was in the Hitler youth group.
That guy literally like actively,
like they know for sure he tried to
shield child molesters like you know that
the he did, they still move
on to the top. There's, it's,
it's an it's outstanding. No, no
debate,
no debate about it.
There's papers out there showing that
they are actively trying to shield charm
monsters and protect the church
from lawsuits and litigation and,
and just try to squash these claims.
I mean they must have,
it must be just an overwhelming
amount of kid fuckers.
I mean it must be like impossible.
The man was there.
No one else to promote to the top.
I don't think so.
When someone in the former heavily
you have, they're all fucked up.
I think if you, he's probably the one
that can sit in his pants the best.
I bet if you went digging
into some of those other guys,
he'd find he didn't fucking anyway,
but he knew about a bunch
of people who are good.
Maybe flux him every now and then
and the rest of them. It's a,
it's a weekend party.
Do you guys think it's most of those
people do it or most not because I think
it's like 99% was dump. Most dumb
people are child molesters. Right?
Like can you look at child molesters
and has nothing to do with intelligence?
You don't think like
that's kind of retired. No,
no.
Flip the baby.
Most of most of what it is is from being
abused yourself. That's what it is. They,
they,
they sort of replay what really fucked
up and damaged them when they were young
and then it just keeps going back and
they did it because someone else had
vampires. Yeah, exactly. It's a re
recurring a problem. It's a killer.
Had charm authored. Yeah. It's, it's
really, it's really a crazy phenomenon.
People that get sexually attracted to
children and sexually attracted to the
idea of raping and you know,
and holding someone down against their
will and that's where they get their
rocks off. It's very, very tricky.
It's really tricky than it happens to
them and then for some reason they wanted
to do it to other people, but there's
been so many cases of that. Yeah.
The best is that guy and I
have to catch a predator.
They call it was like a second time
or no, it wasn't that time. It was,
they caught him and as soon as they
call them they were like, he was like,
can you just send the cops in here and
have them execute me already? Oh yeah.
Yeah. He was like, I don't want to do
this, but this is all I want to do.
Imagine that's all you wanted to do
and I can't help myself just fuck.
I know it's gross. Yeah. That's
what I'm into. It's fucked.
It's fucked. Yeah. He's,
his brain was wired fucked up.
No.
Could you imagine if your brain was
wired great in every other way except for
this whole,
except yeah.
And so you're smart enough to
be aware this is frowned upon.
So it had to be some kind of therapy.
Like they could have made like a
fleshlight baby for them. And then just,
I tried this sink that's helping.
I think that if it,
if it helped them not fuck a kid
and like get into this flashlight,
real doll baby, there's pills you
can take. Right? Give it a cute face.
They give them pills to like, I don't
have no, what they do. I don't know.
I don't know. What's the, I mean
how the and libido little comb,
depress the Harrison.
It's different for every person.
What was trading at one dude,
he's not going to treat down
another dude does have lots.
How much resources are going to do
and straightening up pedophiles.
You got to kill him. There's too many
people in the world as it is. We know.
We know that we,
we just,
that's sort of what I think
in the grand scheme of things.
Just a couple of numbers. You Shit
you supposed to call it all agree.
We don't want them around the
dogs that do the same shit.
When dogs go to bite people,
man,
I firmly believe that those dogs should
be put down and I put down dogs that
were aggressive to people.
I've had dogs in my past that bit
people and we had to put the dog down.
It happened more
than once. Yeah. And uh, I think
that's what you have to do.
I really don't think if you
train a dog and you, you know,
you love them and you're around them,
but something's still wrong with that dog.
And that dog wants a bite.
People like, what's going on?
Why is this dog even associating people
with danger and people with wanting to
attack them.
No one's been fucking with this dog.
You've had it since he was a
puppy. Every now and then, man,
you get a nutty dog and you've got to
kill him. You've got to kill those nuts.
Yeah, because so look man, what the
fuck I had the dog with this temporary,
your dog had a doberman with to Stanford.
He tried to bite me once and it was just,
I didn't know he had to stand up.
My dog has an oral fixation that won't
stop licking and biting and eating and on
dogs. Dude, you got to give
him Roger. I do, but it's
nonstop. Like now it's like he,
she self-medicating,
he's like,
she has this thing that like a squeaker
toy that she just keeps her mouth 90% of
the day. Like she knows like if I take
this out, the rubber dog, Dick. Yeah,
call the fleshlight people.
You have to make a very firm rubber dog
eat dog dick that has like a meat flavor
to it. A fleshlight baby.
Yeah, that'd be great.
Flashlight babies for my dog.
Dogs are awesome when they're awesome.
But the bottom line about dogs
is that there are animals, man.
We were just sort of have this weird
trust and a bunch of animals that can kill
us and we keep them in our yards and
shit and people also put like emotional
attachments on them.
But then if you look back on 50 years on,
you're killing your dog because he
was biting people. They'd be like,
this amount percentage, they don't know
your attachment. They'll just be like,
this percentage of dog was killed
because they bought somebody.
Here's a crazy story.
There's two people that I know that have
had a pit bull fights in the yard where
they had dogs and the pitbull wind up
killing another dog and they're killing
another pit bull or killing a dog and
both of them tried to blame it on some
other shit. Like what? One of
them blamed it on a mountain lion.
One of them thought that a mountain
lion came in and killed a dog.
That's what everyone was saying.
But then my friend Bud said, listen,
I know those dogs and those
dogs used to fight and they,
that fucking idiot had two females in
his yard trapped up together and they
fought in one killed the other one and
he wanted to blame it on a mountain lion
and I went,
ah,
okay,
that makes sense because
why would a mountain lion
coming to a house full of pit
bulls like Jesus?
Isn't there like a better way to eat?
You know how fucking id you have to
be you guys with your mountain lions?
I wouldn't have a mountain lion story.
Like I was at the grocery
store in a mountain lion
jumped on my face where I was
living in Colorado because
where I was living in Colorado,
man there they lost 160 plus houses.
I think it was like 170 total, 179
maybe fire. They had a horrible fire.
The worst fire in Colorado history because
if you think about 170 houses in this
area, this is extremely rural.
This is a mountain community.
So it's all houses in the
mountains and 170 of them are gone.
So a huge amount of forest was burned
down thousands and thousands of acres.
So now mountain lions have less
territory where there's woods and there,
you know the,
they're already like,
they are in an area around people
and they do kill people's dogs.
They want to like,
they want to keep that open as an option
and they know that there's a lot of
around where
people are because of the fact that
people aren't killing the deer because
people are killing the deer in boulder.
Deer everywhere.
So that brings in mountain lions.
So now they have like more and more
mountain line signings there. Wow.
But coming in,
so then the other one about the dog,
the other dog story with a dog killed
another dog or this guy blamed it on
someone I know this dude who
sells weed and uh, he, uh,
was growing plants in his background.
He told me this crazy story where
someone broke into his house and,
and stabbed his dog and
killed his dog and then,
and then to run it ran away with
his plants and I was like, Whoa,
that is fucked up. Like you came home
and your dog was dead and then you know,
you cut your plants.
Uh,
well in time this story has morphed and
now what I've learned is one of the dogs
was a bulldog of female bulldog and the
other dog was a pit bull and the pit
bull more than likely
killed the female dog.
And he's like blaming it on like what
about the plants that are going well,
when he took the dog to the hospital,
because if dog was fucked up,
his neighbor who had been
eyeballing is plants,
hopped over his fence and chop
to shit down, stole his weed.
Every time somebody tells me sort of
crazy, unbelievable story, I'm like,
it's this reason. There's an
unbelievable, it's just not true. Well,
there's some good stories that are legit,
but that ain't one of them that I
was a mad at this guy like, man,
you made me feel like your
dog got stabbed. You know,
and then that felt for that poor dog
getting murdered by some, you know,
some fucking asshole just
wants to steal a plant.
And then I realized that this
idiot's got two female dogs.
I was willing to accept that if it
was two beta fish oil to females,
female dogs, man, female dogs do
not deal well with female dogs.
It's one of the things you like,
you know,
you can really learn a
lot from about nature,
from watching female dogs interact
because female dogs never choose an Alpha.
They don't,
they don't give up.
Like if you beat it like squeaky and Lucy
where my two dogs, they're both sweet,
sweet dogs to people. But both,
he would fight you for attention.
Like if you were petting one of them,
the other one would come
over and grout or like pitch.
But I get the fuck out of here. That's
my hand. I'm gonna get this pet.
And they hated each other because this
and they would never give up no matter
how much they fought,
no matter how many times they would,
I would have to separate them with hoses.
Sometimes they would bite each other
and Claude each other and go crazy.
And in the middle of a fucking picnic,
right. Everybody would be just chilling.
And then once you know,
someone would give one dog a bone and
the other dog would get fucking crazy.
And before you know it,
it's on check thing.
Like it is like your dog should
get a podcast. It is like, and you,
you realize like that's
just a nature thing.
Like there is a natural predisposition
to not want other women around you.
The other, especially other women that
are competing for affection. Attention.
That's why those women who hate their
daughters when they're too hot and they
can no longer hot. Yes dude, that's
dark. That is some dark scary shit.
When you got an old lady,
he was hating on her pre young daughter.
She's 37 daughters,
17 and looking good and I've seen it man.
I've seen it happen many, many times on
her daughter in public. Take the legs out,
every guys who their fucking
girlfriends mom comes
on to them. Wow. How about that?
Yeah, my mom's still sorta got it.
She's like 46 and kind of clinging on
there and I knew that this girl from Texas
who uh, her mom in her is like, like
she's a slant to grind in from Texas.
You actually know her too.
I and the mom is a slut,
like an older version of her and like
they'll come over and have parties like in
high school and college and like her mom
would come out in like short tits and
fucking like, it was just
like, like hanging out.
Like she acted like she
was one of the kids. Whoa.
And she still does it today though with
with her, her Margaret. It doesn't,
but doesn't she get like super
rational and irrational fights too? No,
she's actually, I mean she works for an
airline and stuff like that, so she works,
I'm thinking of a different
girl. Yeah. Oh yeah.
We still have to talk about this so I'll
know exactly what the file often do you
guys bring up stories and you're
like, and this said, said person went,
we always try to edit around them as
much as they're particularly embarrassing
about a close friend.
Very difficult. Yeah.
You don't want to throw people under the
bus. That bugs the shit out of me, man.
When I watch TV shows or listen to a
radio shows and people throw their friends
under the bus too, probably
she was doing heroin with, uh,
some dudes. You could just talk about
anything like Joey Diaz, like you,
you don't have, you don't
even have restrictions. He
doesn't give a fuck. Yeah,
I can tell that story. It doesn't care.
I mean, he'll tell you stories about me.
I was fucking Facebook east. He
wrote that he invited the, uh,
the guy he kidnapped 23 years ago
to be friends with them on Facebook.
And then we got accepted his request.
Diddy, diddy. I Dunno. I Dunno.
We need to find out.
He's probably getting it.
Getting harassment charges filed against
Joey does, right. It's been 30 years.
I was kidnapped.
She wasn't kidnapped.
He was held at gunpoint to a new house
to be like, where's your, where's your,
as the drugs? Yeah. Yeah. We took
it from one house to another.
And you've got to think that. No, he
tied that guy up, bro. Oh really? Yeah.
He tied that guy up and he had a machine
gun. It wasn't like a light crime.
Wasn't like he was jaywalking and they
got out of control. It's pretty intense.
It was already doing some shit. Yeah.
And on top of that, the, uh, well,
the guy was selling drugs and you've got
to think, anybody who's selling drugs,
who's selling drugs back then was
in the 80s. It was like the 80s.
This is how drugs are real.
Yeah.
He can't that can't assume that guy's
still alive. I'll be that guy. Be a lot.
That's someone else at the same name.
I live,
I grew up totally different than
mountain lions and muggings from
Columbus, Ohio. I was upper middle class.
You never ran out of milk and Columbus.
It's everywhere.
People make their own
milk. Holy Cow. Tipping.
But was it like growing up in
Columbus and then you know,
eventually realizing that the rest of
the world wasn't like that? You know,
I was thinking about this last night,
how weird it is that like my high
school in my school growing up,
there was only like two Asians. All
right. There was one girl, one guy,
the girl was named [inaudible],
which was a video game that was
popular or a company at that time.
So she was like, who is this Asian
girl? And she has the coolest name ever.
Kidnap me. Wow. And the guy,
I was his friend and we
grew up together and my only
Asian thing was like,
I was like in love with this Asian girl.
Like she was like the only
person like her of the kind.
And that's where I think I got like Asian
fetishes from one girl. That one girl.
So did someone else date this one
girl? Uh, no. She wished very shy.
You know,
I would buy her and those pencils that
used to take out the end and and put it
in the back by bottom. They
have like little cartridges
now. Oh yeah, I know. Yeah.
Yeah.
It was a big Japanese girl thing anyways,
like she would give me like a pencil
and then I'd go, oh, this is nice.
And you know, no, no. And then I had,
I had Asian several years later
and it was like, you know,
it was just regular sex and totally
broke down those walls. And now my,
the Asian fetish was gone.
But it doesn't,
Nick Adams stories talks about having
sex with an Indian for the first time and
then no girl would ever compete
without brown skin. Like plump woman
from India or from America,
American native American.
Those bitches are probably wild.
Those are crazy jungle bitches.
It was weird about Mexicans.
It's like out here,
you're pretty much 50% 50 and
Mexican and white almost, you know,
short most everyone in
Columbus, Ohio, there was like,
I don't even remember any Mexicans.
Like I remember there was like when the
Mexican race started coming to Columbus
and everyone's like, oh my God, sell
your house, sell your house, you know,
type thing. Yeah, yeah. I
pretty much lived, had a house,
a three bedroom house that my
mom gave me. Yeah, I grew up,
she got remarried and she was like going
to sell and she's like, Yup, you want,
you just have it, you know, you know,
I do not have it but you, I mean he,
she owned it so just live there.
And uh,
I was living there for like three or
four years and I just remembered the
neighborhood slowly starting to see
more Mexicans and to us they were like,
so what was the problem?
People would freak out. No,
it was just that you can
tell the neighborhood crime.
Like my car started getting broken into,
it's during the Mexicans from, no, no, no,
no. I'm just saying at this time period,
this is the facts that happened. And then,
uh, my told my mom, I'm like, mom,
I love this house but I think you
should sell the house pretty quick.
And so she's like, all right. So she
sold it and then like two years later,
that neighborhood is fucking destroyed.
It looks like straight out of Mad Max.
Like the apartment sign is like,
she crumbled down and do your
mic is like really hot? Is it,
is it harder than everybody else's?
Are you doing on top of it? You know,
I'm just probably just on top of it. Um,
did, um, so did this, was this engineer,
cause they do that, you know, they, they
do what's called blockbusting but right.
Real estate agents will go
door to door and they say,
hey Mike guns are moving in.
Yeah. You saw your shit now.
Well I think they actually did
move in now. That's the difference.
It would actually be like the British
are coming the legs of Paul Revere Shit.
But it's weird how like in Columbus,
like you said,
like we only had like the mix mud,
the puppy, you know, like the mud.
I didn't grow up with different races
and the only racist we knew like Italians
were all Italian. You know, they're
were just like, that's weed through it.
And three Italians, they all exactly
the same. That's how that race acts. But
Armenian, see, they still
wear gold chains. Gold chains
eat a lot. They're very
friendly. You know,
they're when Lasagna away from having sex
with each other, you know, it was just
crime went up when the Mexicans moved in.
It was clearly the Mexicans were causing
the crime. Right. Well it seems like,
but it seemed like the poverty caused
it. But if, if, if the Mexicans moved in,
you got to think that you're talking
about lower echelon or class four ports
were different team,
different Mexicans and the ones out here,
something happened to a new job,
open up a new factory or some shit
started migrating. I
think you know, lately,
I mean I noticed from zero Mexican too,
like a lot of Mexicans in Columbus,
Ohio within five years.
Yeah. But isn't there something
that draws them? They're like,
don't they must have jobs.
There must be something.
I think there's been a migration,
Marilyn.
There weren't very many when I was
growing up, but now there are more
pull man. It's just diluting
out everywhere, you know?
And I think they're just
slowly, it's starting like,
seems like it's, they told her
want to move into a platelet. I
know there's a lot in Colorado, man.
A lot of Mexican Martinez was there.
Fantastic Mexican food.
There's a place called pop who
says in Boulder, Holy Shit,
you got to get the maneuver noodle.
It's the real deal man.
Oregon's in there and bones and shit.
Menudo and there's fucking spectacular.
That's what minuto is. Oh really?
Udo is, it's not a bank. I was a
gay man and he was a band, but it's,
it's also a soup. It's this crazy
like beef and pork soup. Um,
and I don't even know what the fuck the
ingredients are cause they're different.
Everywhere you go,
everybody's got their own different
way and make them a noodle.
But what it is is some disgusting,
fantastic,
beautiful creation of where someone's
not even worried about what something
looks like.
There's bones in there and literally
stomach tripe and there's pieces of
Oregon's like pieces of liver. It's
delicious. It's fucking fantastic.
And it just looks like how it looks like,
how it's so good.
It's supposed to be really
good after hangovers too.
And if anybody knows anything
about hangovers, it's Mexicans.
They know what the fuck to do.
They've got it down to a science,
throw a bunch of organs and bones into
a bowl and fucking keep that shit up.
Mexican women are so horny.
Are they? Yeah, no, no.
My friend has this Mexican girl.
Every time I see him together with her,
it's just nonstop. She's on
a grinding, she's moaning.
She's like kissing his neck.
She has three kids. Two,
three separate. Yeah.
No,
just 20 line.
But she is fucking so high and that's
all she does. She has one drink.
She has just, Whoa, what
a good kid. Yeah. Well,
there's a reason why there's a lot
of Mexicans. Okay. It's just a fact.
They're debriefing. Yeah. So the
Mexican girl and you know, it's fine.
The Mexican guys are awesome. Rapist.
Yeah. The Mexican girls must be horny.
There's just no other way around it.
Even though a lot of Holocaust,
why would they love babies?
You know the problem,
I know if I hung out with a girl,
I got Super Hot Latino's 21 and she had
three babies and there was no condom
around, I'd still be like, ah, fuck.
Okay. Right. Let's just chance it. Yeah,
you would probably fucker. And then
later I'd be like, what was I do? Well,
in the poorer communities,
man, it's a problem having
kids, you know? It's like in,
in,
when you get older,
the real issue is the reason why people
want abortions because they don't want a
kid ruining their life, quote unquote,
you know? But in poor communities, like,
oh my gosh, she's got to have a baby.
She's only 16 months of crazy know,
like they don't, they, you
know. Oh yeah, your Mama. She
was only 16 too. It's crazy.
The both got the same shit,
you know,
and like it's okay and everyone's
living together so it's all right.
And they all help take care of the
baby and it's all family. You know,
poorer communities.
What they do is there's more of them
in smaller places and they have like a
tighter knit sense of family.
You get a big ass place with a,
a family that's like spread
out where you either,
mom's never over the house
and grandma's never over.
It's like you see them on rare
occasions and holidays and shit.
That's not all Mexicans rocket.
They stack everybody together.
Let's all get in a house together.
That's really a better way to [inaudible]
family's cool. My friend's fiance,
she is big into like
rescuing dogs and stuff.
She hates Mexicans because
of the way they just like,
they take puppies and then they're
just, yeah, they're adults now.
Let them go and they just wander around
aimlessly in those neighborhoods.
The Mexican sign them
when you're really poor,
you don't fucking give a shit about dog.
You're on team people and you know,
that's just how it goes.
Yeah, I could see that too.
If I was Mexican or if I was poor
and I was living in some communities,
probably loved dogs and everything,
but there's only so many
things you can think of.
No thing number one is you gotta get
the fuck out of this crazy neighborhood
then worry about dogs.
So did you see the vice guide to
North Korea? Yes. That one is crazy.
How they like the food they don't have,
they have really shitty,
crappy food and they have this whole
display that tricks you into thinking that
they have a budget. Well, we're not
doing a good description description.
First of all gets vbs.tv and there's a
show called the vice guide to travel and
they go all over the place. The
scariest one, my favorite ones, Liberia.
But the North Korea one
was interesting too.
And what Brian is trying to say is that
what they did is they set up the whole
situation because they knew that these
guys were journalists to try to trick
people into thinking that they
have this luxurious way of living.
Then it's just like the Western world
and even though they are a communist
society and they're run by a dictator
that you know how we can go get something
to eat, but all these things they realize
we're just set up for them. Right.
When they went to [inaudible], there was
no other patrons. Tables were set up.
There was waiters and waitresses,
but there was no one else.
There were just some things like
house or so it wasn't, yeah,
they weren't real restaurants.
They literally set up food for these
people and set up like a servers so that
they would have good propaganda.
So they would,
and they would bring out really good
looking food and put it on all the other
tables. Almost like if it was like a lax
Turkey, you know, so like it looked like,
wow, look at all that really good
food and then he would get served.
What he said was like, you
know, over fried crap. You know,
like it was horrible food. They weren't
really a restaurant. I'd love to.
So it was like a trick. The whole thing
was like a tree. And what's crazy is that,
that's almost like the whole country Oman
is, are they just as huge chick? Yeah.
They have nuclear weapons, you know, they
do. Yeah. They do have nuclear weapons on.
It's too late. I mean, the, the
real issue is stuck now. It did.
So that's an old school dictatorship.
There's one guy who's running shit
and he's got nuclear weapons. I mean,
that is a, that's a rare situation
where you have one guy who's, you know,
essentially running a whole country
and the military is gigantic.
They have like a million people
in their military military shoot.
You would suck those
that, that, that host guy,
I don't know if you
remember this part at all,
where he got drunk and he was hanging
out with like a soldier doing karaoke
singing and he had assaulted them somehow.
It was that drunk.
He was just being a drunk dude.
Like he was just a Bajic.
The host is when I'm saying,
oh the fat guy. Yeah. He,
that guy annoys the fuck out of me. Not
host. I'm sorry if he listens or anything.
But that guy was kind of annoying and kind
of Douchey had assholey. Yeah, I dunno.
Well you know,
I mean I think he felt like that guy was
playing them to them and that guy was
his like, you know, the guy was
like a, a personal propaganda agent.
He's probably trying to fuck with the
guy just even for the film to make the
film more interesting.
You know, try to get it.
But he said something
if it was really mild,
so whatever he said and insulted the sky,
what does that got really crazy?
Where he wanted to kill him now was for
vice guide. Yeah. It's, well it's a,
it's a web show. You could watch it on the
web. vbs.tv. It's fucking fantastic, man.
There's so much shit there.
I have problems with meet with,
like for me it's like one o'clock in the
morning. I have to decide, okay, I'm,
I can't watch documentary
now because if I do,
I'm not going to sleep
for like five hours,
so I'm just going to stay up and I'm just
a good cause I'll go one to the other
to the other.
Then I start writing and start writing
things down about these different
documentaries and the VBS places,
the worst website to go to at one
o'clock in the morning for me.
Cause that's just doom.
I just go right off the deep end and
then you go and start looking at the
Internet and I start,
yeah,
read the research and other sources and
writing things down and make sure we're
talking about this on
the podcast and you know,
write a bit about that and how the fuck
is this still going on in 2011 blah,
blah blah.
Did you hear what Trent Reznor
did the other day? I mean,
this is what's so fucking
cool about Trent Reznor. He,
he just released a website that has every
single tour date that he's ever done,
you know, and like the last back past
20 years or whatever. And you know,
they have all the tours aren't,
you know,
and then they're adding soundboard audio
from each tour and you could download
it for free. So I um, I went back
and found like the dates that uh,
I went to see him and I'm going
to like as much the ones I wanted,
I went only a couple of a
half the whole concert. Yeah.
And you can have a whole concept of free,
the one that you went to
like fucking 15 years ago.
This is going to be a trip for me.
Hoarded every concert he ever,
I guess so like only, I mean there's a
lot of them that are up yet, you know,
but there's a lot of them that are, you
know, that's going to crush it. So, oh,
it was so crushed when I got it yesterday.
Right when he announced it and
it was like five minutes. I was,
you couldn't even get on it. Yeah.
I was downloading one and it said,
you're like a estimated
down like three days.
I would like to find my guys is
bandwidth fees are going to be for this.
How does he pay for the longest?
He's got money, he's balling.
He's all like yolked out now. Trent Reznor
is like a kid and it's a big meathead.
He's got like a big thick neck and shit.
She would come on the podcast,
he would be the most interesting
podcast. You make. Nice. Nice with him.
A long time ago you met
him backstage and you know,
you proposed us ever talking about
this quarter? No. Great Story.
Cool story. You know, so like before
the Internet was like big at all.
I don't even think it existed or just,
you know,
me like schools had it or whatever.
Um, what you were talking about. Oh,
this is like 93 maybe. I don't know.
Internet wasn't much. It wasn't much.
Um, I was a manager of
a record store and, uh,
I used to always have free cds and stuff
like that and I'm just sitting at my
home. What's going, man, I wish I could
meet Trent Reznor and he was like my hero,
you know? And, um,
so I looked at the back of the CD and
there was an address I said like a
whatever, nothing records Cleveland,
Ohio and had like a zip code or you know,
and had the whole address. So
I wrote this thing saying, Hey,
I'm a manager of a record store.
I have like a nine inch nail fan club
that it's about 100 people read this
newsletter I do and stuff.
And I was wondering if there's any way
I can interview them or take photos,
you know, and stuff. And they're like,
of course, as soon as a copy of it.
So I was like, Oh fuck,
now I have to make a copy.
So I did like issue seven and it had like
letters to the editor or where it was
like sound, what's Trent,
you know, favorite food. And
I would like make shit up.
He built a fake news letter
with the fake news letter.
I have it somewhere in my house and then,
and then, uh, had like fake articles,
take that thing and scan it.
I know it's somewhere a great story.
You should tell him to tell that
story and put the scan that,
that newsletter and put it online. Right.
I should cancel it. And so then you know,
a couple of, was it eight by ten eight
by 10 it was about five pages long.
And so then this person called
me actually back and goes, dude,
we love this newsletter.
You can have any concert
on track record label,
any Marilyn Manson concert. It's any,
you know, anything on his regular,
you get full access backstage, you get
full photo passes to anything you want to.
And so welcome aboard,
Brian. This is awesome. Whoa.
And so then I just started going
to every single concert possible.
I got to hang backstage. I mean, I was
talking to Trent and taking photos.
I was the thing that made me the worst
people are back there. I don't know.
Not many.
I mean 2030 at a time.
At one of 20 and 30 how many other
ones were quote unquote journalists?
I think I was the only one. I
mean, yeah. What was kind of crazy?
It's being imagined. This if you, if
you grew up loving nine inch nails,
um, maybe 18, 19, something like that.
And actually I was younger
than that. It's like 17. Yeah.
And so imagine going from your, like
your idol. I mean, Trent was my idol.
He was the only musician I like.
Then going to hear like here's
the stage Trent's right here.
I'm taking photos. He sees me and starts
singing right into the, into the camera.
So I have all these photos where he's
just screaming right into my camera and
I'm going to have a real camera.
I used my dad's old camera.
I was trying to learn how to
use in a manual film camera.
And so half the photos are blurry, but
it's probably cool that they're blurred.
Some of them are crazy,
like really cool thing that makes
me mad that they are aligned.
They've been online, a nine inch
nail, red ban on Google. Uh,
I'll find it. But, and then, um, so then I
used to, you know, go to Marilyn Manson's.
I did it with Marilyn Manson.
And one time I was hanging out
backstage with Marilyn Manson,
this is when Marilyn Manson first came
out and he was like, you know, people,
you know and stuff like that. And he goes,
Brian, go, Ugh, do you live around here?
Around here? Right? And I'm like, yeah,
I live across the street. And he goes,
go get me a razor. And I'm like, really?
Okay. Marilyn Manson, Marilyn Manson,
Marilyn Manson told you, go
get a razor. Yeah, yeah. Well,
and there was all these fans around him,
like what chicks and shit like that.
There was women, uh,
block, like the tour bus,
they were laying on the street in front
of the wheels so they couldn't drive
away what blog that's on Flickr.
But if you just Google red band nine
inch nail photos or something like that.
Or in I n photos, um, so,
so, so, so, so Merrill man,
so he taught, tells me to get a rage.
So I go inside running crappy razors,
run back and he's like, thanks, watch
this Bryan, this is fucked up. Hey,
who wants me to shave a circle
on the top of their head?
And then these girls like, so just this
beautiful woman comes up and she's like,
I want you to do it. And he
goes, he starts to shaving it.
A little bald spot on the top
or here like a month. Wow.
Whoa. Like a ballpark. Yeah. Wow. And
they were into it. They were like,
those photos are,
you look at that.
And you know what's also
crazy is a hanging out with
Jim rose circus, uh, member,
those guys. Jim Rose Circus.
Yeah. Behind them. That's all.
Back in the day I used to,
you know,
hang out with them too because they used
to open up for nine inch nails and you
just being backstage with
like the puzzles, peep guy
guys. Great photos. Yeah. That
was like, I mean, I didn't know.
I have no idea what I was doing. Folks,
if you just Google, go to flicker,
F L I C K r.com.
And uh,
you just Google red band n I n photos
and I'll take you to the website.
Yeah,
they're fucking great photos and I wish,
I wish Trent Reznor would come on this
podcast. You know him? No, no. I mean,
I'm back in the day, it was like he
was just blowing. That was during the,
you know, when he was just becoming
big, you know, like fuck me,
like an animal and all that crap.
That was a huge song and
people, and so I also did, I also did a
remake of that. Did he really did know?
He did hurt. Oh, that's the,
yeah. Yeah. Imagine if you
did fuck you like an animal.
That gravelly old man voice.
I was talking to this girl the other day
about that and they were like, she goes,
I love this song. It was hurt.
And then I was like, yeah,
I like the original better though.
Accident. She goes, she goes, oh,
what are you talking about? This is the
original. I'm like, no, nine inch nails.
And she had no idea.
He wouldn't really use those words,
hey songs to really be up on all of them.
There's no way.
What's it? It's, it's weird because
I've done that a times where I'm like,
this is an awesome song. Not Realizing
I wasn't even the original song.
I heard buffalo soldiers.
I mean it was a buffalo who did, um,
what's the name? It was Neil Young. Right.
And Bob Marley. Bob Marley. Somebody.
You know who's the guy who we did one
of his songs. Oh, I shot the sheriff.
Who did, who did we did that. Eric
Clapton. Yeah. I'd only heard that.
And I heard Bob Marley's version
and I was like, what is this?
Who is that girl sweet seam
in the middle of sucks. Yeah.
It's Kinda weird that people can do that.
Just kind of like Redo your shit. Yeah.
That most people don't know.
It's weird.
And you don't have to try to get
our mission right. I don't know.
If you get permission, you have to
pay them by the moral duty. Yeah.
But it's weird.
You know,
like sometimes I think it should
be better if it was like this,
I don't think it would be better
if it was like that. Like, man,
go write your own fucking
song every now and then.
Then it comes out bad ass though.
There's a few ones.
There is a kid cutty song that I forget
the name of the female that re did it.
Uh, one of his songs hundred times
better at sort of girls singing it.
Then came up with the version of smells
like teen spirit. It's pretty great.
Yeah. Tori Amos, that bitch you
stole wail on that fucking piano.
She's one of the weirdest singers ever,
man.
It was something like super hyper sexual,
fucking creepy Weirdo about Ryanair.
Everything singing,
screaming into the piano
when she's fucking slamming.
Now you can barely understand the words,
but brilliant piano playing an
incredible voice. I was a preacher.
Wasn't that one of molestation son.
Oh Wow.
Girls.
Some girls saying grammy winning artists.
Yeah.
Boy, you best pray that I bleed real
real soon. How's that thought for you?
That was one of her lines.
Remember that boy,
you best pray that I bleed real soon.
I'm like fucked up.
That's fucked up and
shot a load in me sparky.
And that's already should have come.
But I hope the next couple of days where
I didn't make people, oh that's curious.
How's that for what?
How the line is boy,
you best pray that I bleed real soon.
How's that thought for you? Wow.
Cause you know I still found a
girl thinks really deep thoughts.
That's the words. What's so amazing
about really deep thoughts. Boy,
you best pray that I bleed real soon.
How's that thought for you?
Like fuck real thoughts. Fucking these
amazing deep here's reality deep girls.
I just want to, you know,
wonder. It's amazing.
Come back to reality. And I sewed
on thoughts from, from girls.
You know,
George Harrison said this once and it's
brilliant quote and I use it all the
time. All I need from a girl
is to be attracted to her.
Everything else I get from a man. And
it's really true. I mean, you know,
you should have women in your life that
you have good conversations with and
that you enjoy their company and you
know, you know, share a lot of interest.
So that's all good. There's nothing
wrong with that, but if you don't,
you're going to be okay.
You know,
as long as you have friends and you
have chicks or you're attracted to,
you know there's guys who live happy lives
contrary to popular belief where they
just have girls that they have sex with
and they're attracted to them and they
have all their interesting time
and fun with their friends.
The bachelor culture for a lot of guys,
man,
that bachelor culture is so fucking
like the idea of being like a bachelor
forever and it's so tempting dudes that
are roped down and terrible marriages
and their wives scream at him and
telecom. Think of her now. I was like,
I'm just enjoying single.
I don't want to deal with
any sort of responsibility.
It's anything that comes attached to
that. Very tricky. It's very tricky.
I am happy,
but I realized that I don't have to be,
I could very well be with some crazy
bet. She doesn't like kids, you know,
or she know.
She has some unfulfilled dreams that she
feels like these children are holding
her back from. That's, that's a, that's
an issue with a lot of girls, you know.
And then all of a sudden there's some
weird resentment because they, you know,
they have to take care of the children
more than the father does cause of
dentist at work.
I have a few friends that had kids
that they did have that issue with.
The wife would be mad at them that they
didn't have to deal with the kids all
day and she would like immediately give
them the kids as soon as they get home
and the wife were just lock herself
in the bathroom and you know,
fill the tub up and wouldn't answer
questions and leave me alone.
Like he'll just as a weird chaos inside
your, your house and your family.
So for guys like that man, and they
have a friend who's like just guessing.
I grew up around a lot of pool
players and a lot of pool players,
our whole lifelong bachelors. Some of
them wind up having kids here and there.
Some of them even get
married for a little bit.
[inaudible] are playing pool till five
o'clock in the morning every fucking day.
And they're gambling,
they're going on the road and they're
going a tournament's that traveling all
over the country and
it's just a wild life.
And in like the 1940s and
the fifties in America,
there was this big bachelor
culture of pool halls.
That's why pool halls were always
associated with like deadbeats and well,
people doing the wrong thing and you know,
bad, bad people hanging out in places.
It's because those are the guys that
didn't get wives and kids and didn't get
regular jobs and just said,
I don't want to be a fucking slave.
I don't want to live a shit life.
I want to have fun. I want to,
I want to pay $10,000 sets
at three o'clock in the
morning. You know, they, it's,
it's just a, they just decided
that it would be more fun that way.
I think a lot of it has
to do with divorces. Yeah.
Fucking divorce is terrible.
Man. Crushes people as what it is.
He goes through one divorce, man.
It ain't like a breakup
man. I have friends. I have,
I have one friend that's been
divorced twice this fucking dumb.
He is in his third marriage now.
He's been divorced twice a week.
Most of those batches are saying
we're had been divorced. No,
I mean I made a divorced family like mom
and dad was divorced. I don't want any,
that's why he was going to be a bachelor
because I know. I don't know. I got that.
A lot of it is bad relationships,
man. It's hard. It's hard to be happy.
I know a few people like that. That's
their version of relationship was bad.
The mom download spot and they're like,
I just don't want to do that. Right.
There's that. Yeah, there's,
they don't wanna get married,
but they don't mind staying with a
buddy. There's that, but there's also,
it's fucking very difficult.
Especially I feel like on the
east coast and the east coast,
I found it much harder because
a lot of the women were harder.
They did have this like a lot of like,
like hard edge sort of, you know, brassy,
tough girl kind of shit, which I don't
find attractive at all. I find repulsive.
Yeah.
Like girls,
like their hands on their hips and
they want to talk shit and getting like
insult battles with you, you know, good
luck hooker, you know, take care of him.
And I'm so not into that like getting
in arguments and chicks. I mean,
how many times have you dated girls
like that? Yeah, most of the time
I'm not into that man. You can't talk
shit to me. You can't talk shit to me.
If you're my friend and you can't
talk to shit. To me, if you're dating,
if you wanna start insulting
me and getting stupid
reasons because they want to
because they're frustrated or they
want to pick on something about you.
And you know, God forbid if you're
not the most successful guy, you know,
God forbid if you know you're,
you're in the middle of trying to put
something together and then they start
criticizing you.
And I've had,
I've had relationships with girls
where they are like, you know,
would critique what I'm doing
and you know what, what,
what's going to happen if that doesn't
pan out for you and talk all kinds of
crazy shit and you're like,
I don't know what's going on but if you
don't pan out for you, what? I'm like,
Bitch, I'm 21 or why? Why are you
getting so crazy? Like what am I doing?
We can settle down. I was
trying to blow loads. Okay.
And that's the only reason why we're
hanging around your my pussy dealer.
You know,
you're my God damn vagina deal and you're
insulting me while I tried to get my
fix. I'm going to have to get it
somewhere else. Black chick, it's cheaper.
That's what it is. Bad. It's like,
it becomes like some sort of
a fucking sex barter system.
You're willing to tolerate
nonsense until you get older.
And then when you get older you kind of
understand who you are and you attract
people that are a little smarter,
a little more experienced in life,
and then you can have real relationships
with people that you actually find
interesting.
When I started going on dates,
I was just trying to make the girl
feel happy, you know what I mean?
Like I was just like,
just have her keep talking Fart
crotch shot, which is have her
keep talking, I'll be fine.
Just make sure she's having a good
time. And then later it's like, oh,
I want to have a good time to just
talk about stuff. For both of them too.
You do an I like, I like finding
a girl that's like really young,
like 22 and then have them
having complete like, all right,
I trust you. You know, like in
here, let me teach you about this.
Let me teach you about this.
And they listen, you know?
So if somebody came to me when I was
22 years old and gave me guidance,
creep gave me guidance, that would
be nice. From who though? Man.
Maybe you shouldn't be giving guidance.
They're looking for a father
like little things like just go rejoin.
Yeah, I guess so. How not to get too high.
Got It. Know when to back off
exactly what your father pay.
You know you don't know when to stop.
You think you're getting drunk as great.
Just take you know, three drinks
and then take a water. I said, oh,
that makes sense. I can do that. It's
like little things like that. Management,
art.
That is very important because I've been
out so many times with people and they
just want to keep going. Come on.
We know the drug Nugent. It's like,
I don't need another drink.
Why do you need me to have another drink?
I'm happy right now. We don't all
need to go to a Bolivian together.
If you want to go to oblivion,
I'll be right here and I'll
tell you what really for,
and I'll show you where your room is.
I don't have to go to
oblivion to stupid enablers.
They're looking for someone to
make them feel better about it.
They're looking for someone to dive with
them. Let's go into this crazy pool.
Come on man. I'm going to the crazy Paul.
Don't you want to go on a crazy book?
You're like, I'll be right
here. Sunbathing right next
to the crazy. Cool. So Brian,
even having a lot of issues with
girls, man in your life, I think,
I think we need to write a book.
Just changed the names to protect the
NSA because this shit is just too good to
waste too much good stuff going on. A soap
opera, Twix, he vixen. He's, Look Brian,
I think it cannot be disputed
that you are in fact a pimp now.
You've got bitches. If I, if
I were all at camp, I didn't,
we wouldn't want to murder
so many bitches. Well,
no pimps loved her murder bitches.
No, I'm not going to murdering lynch.
Are you concerned to think
that I would exiting ready? Oh,
you mean like if somebody else murders
her, that could be happening. The podcast.
Oh see we don't do this like a lot of
those other guys, Bro. This is live.
Okay. This shit is going to get
out on the Internet no matter what.
It's on the Internet right now already.
They're probably chopping
this thing up and making,
making a video of that as we speak.
So you should be careful.
You should be very careful what you say.
You're paranoid. No, not you. I'm shit.
Seriously.
We shouldn't,
we should change the names to protect
the innocent and you write a book days of
your lives too. Cause it's fabulous. The
story is fabulous. You what you should do,
you really should do what you really
should do is start experiments.
What do you mean like with them?
Yeah,
it start life as an experiment show just
like yours. Yeah, I know. I'm sorry.
We're in the labs. We are in the labs.
What are you going to talk about you?
We're talking about gardening. Um,
there was a few people when I used to,
when I first moved to California.
One of the weird things is when
you meet people that are like,
I'm sure you've met a ton of these people
that are in a open Mike nights that
have no chance. There's zero
chance. Yeah. Yeah. What does that,
how weird is that feeling?
That's why you staying with this.
You've been in this more than
like three times. Like why? Yeah,
there's something absolutely wrong with
them there for a couple of years and
you're like,
you're not getting any response.
So they would become my science
projects and I would, uh,
I would literally like make notes.
I'll be like, okay, now I see some,
some resentment starting to show up.
We didn't have resentment before,
but now there's some resentment.
We're about five years into this thing
and now they see that other people are
actually making a living and
going out and getting gigs.
And I would like be in the back of the
comedy store and people would be pissed
that no one would take them on the
road with them. And I'm like, whoa.
Like you don't even see your own
sense of why do you think you should,
like you're not good, you don't do
well. Those are the weirdest nights.
When someone would go up, like Damon
Wayans would show up and uh, you know,
out of the, in the middle of
like Sunday night, you know,
they'd be a lineup and you know,
a bunch of comics like maybe get on,
maybe you don't.
And then Damon Wayans would show up and
some guys put fucking Bull Shit, man.
What the fuck man, he's taking my fucking
stage time. And you're like, Whoa, whoa,
Whoa, Whoa, dude,
you really shouldn't be on stage at all
on Sunday and it's probably going to get
up there. Let's be honest. You were only
going to get up there and show off. Yeah,
exactly. That's the other problem.
They would do the same stuff.
It's all or the commerce store. I hate
it when people come in, like on Sundays,
on Monday nights,
the pop pop a night and they go on
like during the employee section. Uh,
but they hate it more if
it just doing the material.
They've all a thousand times.
Like,
why did you come here during our sets to
come to the same crap you've been doing?
The only reason why I could see anyone
wanting to do that as if you're just
looking for a tuneup set, you know, it's
like you, yeah, that'd be fine in a while.
And you want to just kind of align some,
showcase something loosen up.
You don't wanna do that on Friday night
at the comedy store was the most the at,
I've never been to a place where people
like felt like you're taking away from
their time.
It's cause you're all junkies and you're
taking away their fucking juice. Yeah.
That's all it is. Stephanie. Ask her,
Hey, don't want David tell came in.
It was like his first time coming in
for like years that I'd seen. And uh,
she was like, you gonna go on and
like, we're all like, oh cool,
we get to see David Toe. And he's like,
Nah, I don't want to bump buddy buddy.
And she was like, I'm sure no
one will mind. It was like,
what are you talking about? Of
course the mind, the letters stand,
but they don't want it to happen.
They'll mind if red Fox came
out of the grave and was like,
I want to go on there.
It's like right after me.
It would be the best time to go on.
People would get pissed. Yeah. Yeah.
It's a tricky thing man.
That the bumping comedians thing and
it gets real tricky when guys use it as
like a douchebag move when
they purposefully do it
and they don't want to call
in, they don't want to, they don't
want to schedule it in advance.
They want that cloud of being able
to just walk in and go onstage. Like,
look at me, I'm here. Forget
what you were doing. Look at me.
I'm here.
I have that problem all the term to you
jumping in like teachers go in there and
just get that love. Yeah. What do
you do with it when you get the love?
Give it to somebody. Oh,
you're so sweet. Some behind.
So, um, do you think this is going to
have a happy ending? Your scenario?
It's pretty crazy right now.
Yeah.
Can you give two hours
too much within a year or you won't get
one bite at all within like a year one?
Yeah.
The summary is in a year.
The other two will both be pregnant with
his baby summary is ex-girlfriend's all
seem to be knowing each other and
combining to form Voltron's of let's work
together to keep each other.
You get him back,
but they know what they're trying to do.
All using each other to,
to get each other,
but to get each other back and I'll
stay in my life. Here's the deal,
dude. As long as you keep smiling, you
win. Okay. As long as you keep smiling,
you always went,
no matter what they do,
if it doesn't hurt your it was when
they're all because, exactly. Exactly.
They become parts of Iraq
building my own material.
And if they're not your act motherfucker,
they're going to be my act.
Cause I'm thinking about talking about it.
Oh they're in my act.
Cause I got a whole a whole bit I've
been working on for years that you pay,
you pay brow, you pattern, no matter what
you pay. It's a fucking, you know. Yeah.
You can't, first of all, you can't fuck
over your head. Don't try. Don't do it.
Don't do it. Fuck. Fuck. People
that are actually attracted to you.
You're your speed. Don't go crazy
when you start fucking over your head.
Once you in the deep water every time,
sometimes that's just fucking over
your head is just a title. Like, wow,
you won this title. If you didn't have
this title, you'd be a little bit,
go ahead. As being above your head.
You know the fuck did you just say,
I'm trying to, I'm trying to
tip toe around things. Joe,
I know what you're trying to do,
buddy. If you're, what you're saying is
that I'll, I'll, I'll, I'll
preface. I'll make it briefer.
What you're saying is that it
seems like they're above your head,
but it's only because they have this
label when in reality they're not,
if they did not have that label of
that one certain award. Right, right.
You are just a crazy fucking
person. That's right. But,
but that's the only reason why I'm
not above my head. That's that.
You know if she's hot as shit. So
sort of is above your head. Well,
see, you guys don't see anything
except the photo shopped version
or what don up to be that
character or hanging out
up to be that character.
If the,
you know how much makeup would be
so popular if that was the case,
if we looked at completely bitches
could just throw something like that.
Pixie dust on their face. We're
not saying you're an ugly guy, bro.
Don't get me wrong. You're a very handsome
young man, young, beautiful features,
especially when you're clean shaven.
Why it takes years.
I've dated some beautiful
women and that's them.
That's not what I'm saying.
What I'm saying goes, yeah,
I know what you're in ones,
which we shouldn't even really talk about
you. I have a better story. There's a,
there's a guy that I know that was
actually a rockstar and he was living with
his check and he eventually got married
to her and she was way harder than him
and everyone knew that it was just a
matter of time. She was just literally,
she just was waiting to
stick a needle in them yet,
not yet.
Not yet
married. See if I can do a year, I'm
at a year. If I could do two years,
I want to make more money.
Let's see if I can make three years.
She made it about three years.
That's not that fucking needle in there
and just talking socking money and blood
out of them and just vanished and change.
It became a totally different person
and hired lawyers who attacked them.
No prenuptial of course. So
she just raping and pillaging
like a fucking monster.
Just tore through his life.
Like all of a sudden she pulls off
her mask and she shows what happened.
He robbed, he got robbed, she robbed
him, she fucked him. She sucked his dick.
She did it all for like three or
four years and then she robbed him.
She literally robbed him. She
made millions and millions
of dollars and he was,
he's a really unattractive guy and he's
small and he's got like little hands and
he's not, he's nothing manly about it. And
this girl is like, she's like an Alpha,
she's the Alpha female, she's
got a hot body, you know,
she's like in shape and young and
the like and, and, and she came from,
she will like other relationships where
she was dating pro athletes and a bunch.
So she had been like targeting people
like for a while and she just went after
this guy and robbed a man and that was a
clear example of fucking over your head
for this poor fuck. And he was just, he
was just bonkers over just bonkers man.
He took her everywhere on
the road with them. Yeah,
I helped letter designed the
house. They built a house. I said,
you got your asshole looked right just
one time and you're fucking hope forever.
Amen. If you're some little weasley dude
with terrible genetics and you know,
just,
you know,
just happened to be like really good at
a certain area of music and you know,
you start making,
you know,
you know people like cheer when
they see you on stage and you know,
this bitch just started racking
up dollar signs in their head.
But the scary thing from all his friends
was how it changed. Like overnight,
like when she decided to sync the needle
in, it was like, all right, game's over,
game's over, game's over. It's all
different. Yeah. And I'll look,
I'm not attracted to you. I'm
not into, I don't love you.
And this poor fuck tried to bring her
back. He tried, he didn't understand.
He didn't get it. He is, something
must be wrong. What did I do wrong?
We can make it work out.
I don't like you just got,
she got crazy and angry. It's so
pathetic. I really, I thought, I mean,
this is the most pathetic I've ever seen.
You just attacking him and
abusing him and his poor fuck.
Tried to keep her around,
you know, just like,
I'm not going to make this marriage hard.
I'm not going to divorce her.
I just want you to be happy. Could I
want to be happy to like just anger,
just no love and just
sock the money from him.
Socked it. Yeah. I got the, I got
the, you know, if we break up,
you'll come walk crawling back
to me. Yeah. I said again again,
and you will, won't you if
you will. I mean, if she be
fucking Hook you, dude, I get
it. They fucking hook you.
If it's three o'clock in the morning
and you're standing there like sort of
halfway committed to masturbating while
you're watching television, you know,
you're like playing with your
underwear while you're watching TV.
Like should I beat off? You know that
that foggy thing for most moment,
don't know this, but most men,
while we're watching TV alone,
we're in a constant state
of semi masturbation where
your hand is always on your
deck and you're always adjusting your
balls or you're rubbing your deck just to
see if Dick would get hard.
Right now I'm watching a
documentary on killer whales.
Let's see if my dick gets hard.
That would be crazy.
If my dictus guard hard right here
while I'm watching these killer whales.
The thumb comes out of your mouth and
onto your, no, don't do that stuff,
but if that was going on,
I mean like you start off,
you're born with your thumb in
your mouth and then you grow older.
It goes to your Dick. Okay. Anyway,
if all this is going on and you're in
your underwear watching TV three o'clock
in the morning and you open up the
door and she was there, you would go,
come on in. Of course, you know mouth. No,
I wouldn't say that, but if she
was, if she showed up in a fur coat,
she opens a fur coat and she said,
shut your mouth.
If you don't,
if you don't call me at three o'clock in
the morning and I'll come over and slap
you that I'll put a camera on it so I
could have the most mediocre sex I've ever
had. All right, sure. That's
not true. No, it is true.
You just got to get
better at making noises.
What's that about?
What kind of,
I guess you could say that
or I can go through the, you
know, no. Dot, dot dot, dot.
Be Nice. But yeah, no, I'm
just saying what you're saying.
I don't know what you're saying, but you
don't need to. I know what I'm saying.
You don't want to do that.
Yeah. Well, you know what, man?
A lot of people that moments of
weakness when I cover headsets. Yeah.
Moments of weakness,
especially with my,
even the ugly ones that are like
jewelry with like four kids did.
I liked when I was like 15
I was still like, all right,
let's do it. I'm very calm,
very little confidence in myself and
my Dick is hard and make smart choices,
especially if I was alone in my house
and halfway masturbating were so mad at
the true trick our first and think
about it as legitimate advice. It works.
This is legit advice.
I used to be.
We used to say that me and my friend
Jimmy to Telia when we lived together in
Waltham, Massachusetts, we would go out
to avoid making fucking big mistakes.
We used to like actively say
that and do it like, all right,
remember you got to beat off first before
you leave the house or you're fucking,
you'll chase after bad dreams and
I would fucking make sure I just,
as a rule, you know, we'd live
together. We had a stack of Pornos,
most of them that I
stole from my stepfather.
I stop fucking cases of
fucking VHS tapes of porn.
I stole some of them bitches when you
can kind of say shit. And he's a mine.
Just turned 12 when I moved out or when
I came back home that I felt terrible.
Two's dad. Yeah, my Stepdad. That's
so great. Oh my God. My playboys.
Always just make sure that you know,
always gotta make sure you peed off
first before you leave the house.
One time I walked in on him PTEN off in
the living room. So impaired or your dad?
No, no, no, no. My friend Jimmy.
Oh, not my stepdad. Did he jump out?
No. No. He's laughing. He's laughing.
He just stopped. He stopped.
He grabbed turn sideways.
I couldn't see his deck.
And he was naked in the living
room. Huh? Well, you fucking free.
We lived a little bit [inaudible]
apartment. Yeah. It was a tiny apartment.
It was just the living room and
two bedrooms. He went there.
And you had two bedrooms. Well,
you know the, the TV in his room.
He didn't have a TV in
his room at the time.
It took me on a TV in the living room.
That's what it was. Was He watching porn?
Do what you gotta do it?
Yeah, he's watching. Oh,
okay. So you had to be there.
I'm like, what? There's gotta
be a reason to do it there.
I said every retired I went to a big,
I think I went to a Gig and I was just
home earlier than he thought. Yeah.
That was the salad days. Back in
the day was Waltham, Massachusetts.
Right in front of Burger King. You
have ever Ingram telling you about? Um,
about when he walked in and his girlfriend
and fucking his best friend. Whoa.
He got home early from Chili's one day.
Oh my God.
Held him off early and he came home. I
was like, whoa. Wow. That's fucking crazy.
That's nuts man. I'm glad
that never happened in the
ad. It would not know how to,
that's such a different trail. It's one
thing if she's fucking some other dudes,
he was letting me stay there.
Like, he was like, all right,
you can stay here while you're,
and then shoes are crazy, man.
Some pitches just can't help themselves
when they're around a man to want to
fuck them and it'll get real close
and they don't mean to do it.
But once their pussy gets wet and that
got touches it and then his dick is hard,
all of a sudden,
oops.
It's in there.
And the friends who's not thinking,
you can't think clearly, man.
Hard dicks or monsters.
They are monsters hard.
Dick's have minds of their own
hard. What'd you think? Oh,
sorry. Heart. Dick's. Yeah,
it was like, what the fuck
is that? That's my new baby.
The most romantic emotional self
help books called Heart Dick. Well,
I'm trying to do is combine
men and woman together.
I mean amount of basically
Dixon women at heart, you know,
and together we're all happy. We need
heart Dick. It's like, uh, like goop.
Like the Gwyneth Paltrow website.
I'll start a website called heart dick.
It's probably already registered
and there's probably some,
some dork out there in Australia right
now to slam my keyboards too late heart
pig doc.
I can see the graphic.
The top would be the head and then we'll
come down to Sioux balls and come under.
Yeah, look like I like
it. Yeah. That's cool.
Or any designer there
and make a heart deck
and you can make the bottom of like
fades to pink and with a little hairs.
Unless you're black, you can get
a black version two. We're hard.
Dick is a fucking big giant
chimpanzee. Black balls. This,
we have the biggest balls ever.
Yeah. If I, if my balls were black,
if I was a black car,
I would want like chimps size balls to
have over micro do a really good joke
about when and he said, uh,
you think I have small shoes?
You think small shoes means Oh,
it was a fucking puppet comic.
A black guy with an old white guy puppet.
That's who told the joke. But he goes,
oh, I know what the girls are.
They could, you must have,
I must have a small dick
cause my small shoes.
Well you know who else had small shoes?
Horses.
That is funny. That old man, Donny.
That's very good because a horse
shoe is only like as big as yeah.
And those decks aren't that passive.
That's, that's actually very funny man.
Horses don't have such big balls.
I don't know. It tastes the same.
Duly grills have a little tiny
ass balls. Really animated.
No, it's true though. Actually going
over this in the podcast before,
but I'll do it just for the point of this.
This particular discussion for people
who don't want listen to every fucking
episode or observe the um,
the,
the size of your balls is directly
related to how many female sluts there are
and your community.
Why am I ball so much bigger?
This is why you grew up with a horse,
or at least my ancestors
did horse for real.
It's true when your body is producing
sperm, a huge amount of their sperm,
like a great percentage of it,
our attack sperm that are there
only around to kill other sperm.
So if a of a guy shoots
a load in some chicken,
then you come in and
you get sloppy seconds,
your lows will go and
kill his loads. Wow. Yeah.
That's why chimps have big balls because
chimp girls or are whores like there's
that bit that I used to do in
my act about a chimpanzees.
It's a true story about fucking,
they did studies on Champs when they
taught them that if they gave them,
they taught them the value of money and
they taught the chimps that they would
give them coins and if they gave
the coins back, they give him food.
So they realize these coins represent
food and they would do things to earn the
coins and then they
would get food from it.
The first thing that champs
did was give the coins,
the female champs and fuck them.
There was the first thing they did.
They went right up to him and they were
like, look, I got this. This is for food.
And the the female chimps would go,
they would get their food,
they would eat their food and they would
just like stick their pussy out him in
the mail chimp because they
wanted to fuck anyway. Well,
they wanted to fuck anyway and they would
allow it like whenever the mail chimp
wanted it right away,
there would have to be him chasing
her around the fucking cage all day.
And then finally she says, okay, fine.
That's what most of it is
a human equivalent to the
sympathy handjob. Exactly.
You know, it's just like in, in the
chimp world, the chimp pimps, you know,
they can just kick back and relax and
then they're more attractive because
they're, they're not constantly chasing
after it. The ones that are on needy,
just like in real life,
if you're all needy,
chasing after grow over and over and over
again, I'll, she's like, all right, fine,
you could fuck me,
but if you don't even hardly talk to her
and all the other girls are talking to
you. And then she's like,
why is he with them?
I'm surprised at how often girls were when
you were like, I don't really want to,
you know, a girlfriend. They're like,
well that's, that's what I want.
And then how many of them like, all right,
that's fine. We'll do it on your terms.
Yeah. But how many of them do it and
try to trick you? They're like, oh,
I want a boyfriend either.
Yeah. It was a few of those.
They give you just
because you're interested.
They're lying to themselves to the reason
why you can keep these non monogamous
relationships. It's just because
you're an exceptional person.
Mr [inaudible] everyone,
she's not dating you.
She's going to be dating some
boring motherfucker. Yeah,
an accountant or something who works
all day and is exhausted at night and I
always get gout getting fucking hyper
hypertension because he's fucking stressed
at work cause he needs to be talking to
his boss about some sort of a promotion
and he feels like there's a glass
ceiling and you know you're dealing with
nonsense man.
At least your fun.
You'd take a check to a comedy show
and she's like, look at this guy.
He gets up on stage. It
makes people laugh. Yeah.
So you're allowed to pull off this.
I don't want a girlfriend shit for a
little way I'm a Dick because if you wake
me up before noon,
that's new. Let me sleep.
It's like we'll have no problem.
I hate that.
Why did they have to all wake up
early? Why go wake up? Just go do it.
Do they really? Oh Man. It's all
see it. Not the girls. I did. Well,
people with regular jobs to wake up early
cause I used to it. That's true. Yeah.
You gotta be careful with a girl has a
regular job or girls that are like hyper
ambitious. C'Mon, let's go hiking. A
hate died. I've never went skydiving.
I want to try skydiving and
you're going to go with me, bitch.
I am not dying on a fucking farm rooftop.
I'm not gonna.
That's not gonna be the last thing I see
as I go through the fucking roof of the
barn. They never go on
vacations. We never go hiking.
We never got to Santa Barbara. Santa
Barbara is amazing this time of year.
Come on, let's go. You weren't around.
I would never even think of doing that.
Yeah.
I mean there's some fun shit you can do,
you know as a couple that you
really can't do with your buddies.
Like I guess you could go wine tasting
or something. It might be a fun,
cool. Go for a drive. Great to
black out and get drunk. It's well,
it's cool to just do different
things, man. And he hurting.
You're hurting inside.
You know, I went to Santa Barbara
and that's what happening with,
there was like five wineries on a row
and he just like walked from each one.
It's so expensive. Getting
a hotel in Santa Barbara, we
can only afford one night,
which was like $350 a lot of wineries too.
Oh yeah.
It starts there and it
was like $350 a night.
So we've got this really nice or actually
it was a pretty shitty, you know, room.
Me and Katie and uh,
we went to like five wineries and then
that's when you walk to them? Yeah.
You just walk a little winery. What, what
they were, they were fronts where like,
you know, like store presence, but you
do wine tastings there and it was like,
you know, down the street or whatever.
But basically drive just to drink wine.
Exactly.
But not even seeing the grapes.
Like I thought that was part of the charm.
You pull over on the side here, next
five miles, it'll be this place.
Go to the grocery store,
graft and grief and look at them.
And named go get to the wine,
go to
Maynard's grape vineyards.
How cool is that?
Maynard from tool [inaudible] vineyards.
Yeah. He's a fascinating guy. My buddy,
Dustin is a sound guy.
You know,
he does a travels and bands and shit
and you know Dustin and Dustin said that
he's a super cool guy. He just
wants to train Jujitsu all the time.
He's apparently really good at
Jujitsu. Yeah. Maynard's uh,
of phenomenal Jujitsu guys like uh,
Hixon Gracie student and like he brings
Dustin with them on the road cause
Dustin can do Jujitsu with them as well,
so and so they'll set up the sound
and they have mats set up. All right,
let's train. And then what he wants to
train for an hour and a half and shit.
Loves to roll.
Go over techniques like really loves it.
Well that last night in the wiener
though, it was, are, you know what I mean?
When we were there that that night after
we went to five wineries puking all
night,
like laying on floor,
can't try to drag her into
bed and she wouldn't go.
So she slept in the toilet.
Wine is so awesome when it's good. You
know, I never traveled like when I'm,
I'm never traveling happier at like
when I'm going through the wine menu,
they'll want, when I'm with
Lichtenberg Lichtenberger you can,
you give that guy the wine menu. You
don't even ask, you know, and say like,
we get this, he just go, dude,
you pick something cool. He
knows exactly what to do.
He'll bring his own wine cozy.
Remember that wine crazy thing.
He has not fucking around.
I go over his house, Bro.
He's got this giant in wine cellar.
It's all temperature controlled.
He's got all these bottles on the walls
and he's got them all like segregated.
These are from France. So these are
California Cath, his hobby. Oh yeah, he's,
well he's a master.
I mean he really knows his shit.
I went to his birthday and
it was a wine tasting party.
I tried writing a bit about it and
I started telling him on stage,
but no one could relate. It was like so
off the charts weird. So I'm there. Right.
And you know, I, I enjoy
wine. It's really good.
But everyone else at the
party is a wine connoisseur.
And so we have this tasting menu with,
they're bringing over these
little tiny plates of food,
like different hors d'oeuvres and stuff.
And then they'll bring over a,
a selection of wines to go with it.
Often two or three different
wines to go with it.
And everyone will go over the selection
and then they'll all talk about it.
So I had a recorder
with me and a recording.
I wish I could find it because it was
so ridiculous. It's like this one has a,
a woody finish this. Yeah. It's
like, okay. And the tannins and,
and then this one is corked. And what
someone would say, I think this one,
it's cork and everyone else had joined.
And I'd be like, this is my favorite one.
The one that you're saying is bad. It's
like my favorite one. Like how do we,
I don't, I don't understand.
Oh, I was all loose.
I mean they have an educated
palate and I'm like,
why would you want your sense
of taste to be that educated?
Why would you want to be so
goddamn specific about wine?
Well, well, what it is kind
of cool about that is there,
there's one I went to where
the winery is next to,
or like a rose garden or something.
And so they were like,
you can taste the roses in it
because it's in the dirt. Oh,
from Tony left a joint next to
Tony. Tony Harris fluff had
joint next to a box in a bag,
in a sealed bag next to a box of um,
uh,
those dryer sheets and the
joint tastes like, yeah,
it tastes like dryer sheets. Oh
my God. Do you exhale only? Yeah.
So this is why is he threw a
sheet zip lock bag. That's crazy.
That just wine though.
A free said taste the roses and like you
drink it and you just have this slight
tit. It's kind of cool being right next
to where the air would get into it. Wow.
That's Kinda freaking, yeah.
Wow. It's two Buck Chuck Berry.
You ever drink two buck chuck?
Delicious. What is that?
Is it particles from the fucking
rose? The sort of what? What is it?
It's private just from over
the years, you know, I've just,
I don't do they really know. Is that
like there's, these are science guesses,
right? This is wineries
talking about their product.
It's the same thing as a joint.
The touching thing too,
I don't know what is it fair? But
what, what happens in the air?
It's like what's traveling
over there? Smells, smell.
That was a little tiny
particles gets in at,
that's why my friends say when you smell
a Fart, it's little pieces of shit.
It is. No, no. That's
why it's so offensive.
Well that's one of the reasons why
grilling over wood is so delicious.
It gets it in the flavor.
Gets it.
That I have is I know how to
cook a steak over mesquite.
I always get mesquite hardwood.
Like if you go to like a whole foods,
they don't sell bearcats
bearcats are all like, you know,
if he bought like Kingsford all and
that Shit, a lot of them, they're,
they're jammed full of lighter
fluid. You know, the way that the re,
the best way to cook is you don't use,
you don't use any lighter fluid.
You just use paper and one of those
cones, you know, they have those like,
they're like a volcano. It looks
like a chimney. That's it all up.
So you pour all the coals in the chimney.
At the bottom there's an
area where you stuff paper.
So you light the paper on fire and
the paper, the, the flames go up.
He catches the mesquite wood, you
lay it down and then, you know,
once it gets to a certain temperature,
when it's like really red, hot and steamy,
then you sear it on each side for two
and a half minutes and you finish it on
the top and it just smells like the wood
and the fucking meat is so delicious.
You're used one of those
chimney sweep logs. Uh,
you know where you put it in and
cleans your chimney out. Those,
I guess it's a chimney out the
fuck are you talking about?
There's a log that clean.
Yeah. You never know that. Oh,
that guy that can't be good
can, can imagine that just
killing it. Killing birds.
That's where all those birds
are falling from. The fucking,
somebody did one of those.
Right. How about this matter?
I was just thinking about this,
speaking of birds a fall from
the sky because this, this,
this really is kind of
bizarre. You know, you know,
when people think about the apocalypse,
you know, people think about, you know,
the end of days and shit like that.
Stuff like that happen.
This is the kind of shit they talk
about, right? Biblical. Yeah. Yeah.
Like dying fish and dying birds and all
these things happening and every dog's
following what is going on with the birds.
They don't,
while they're still good autopsies, but
they're saying all kinds of crazy shit.
Like some of them say that the,
the birds like got scared by sound
and slammed into, into a houses.
Yes. Yesterday. Where's
Chicago? They're lying for sure.
But here's the thing. They,
they're guessing and they're trying to
come up with some sort of an answer cause
I don't think they're really know.
You know, they're saying that these,
these birds have a, uh, have their
showing trauma on their body, of course,
are shown the trauma. They fell
from the fucking sky. Retard,
like the idea that they ran into houses
and that's how they died at stupid
because there's not broken houses. I
mean weren't all around. Yeah, exactly.
And there's,
there's no way they would all be like
near the house if they're all slamming in
the houses,
they would all be right there up inhale
eventually melted when it came down
lower stacker hilltop.
It could be it,
that definitely can be or it could be
some poisoned shit. Yeah. You know,
we talked about that John Wheeler Guy,
that guy that was assassinated,
he was a chemical weapons expert and uh,
you know,
he was a chemical weapons expert under
George Bush's father and he was involved
somehow in other with the
current administration,
they found this guy tortured
and murdered in a landfill.
And this was like right along the time
that all this shit was going down,
you know,
with these birds falling from the sky and
these hundred thousand fish turning up
dead, you know, and massive fish
kills. Sometimes that should happen.
Sometimes you know,
sometimes things go wrong or pollutants
getting the water or you know what?
If it's just government testing,
it could be more,
it could be them testing chemicals.
Receiver theorist won. Yeah,
well you know fucking the problem with
conspiracy theories is some of this shit
is really going on.
The primary conspiracy theories is
people want to come up with a theory for
everything.
A lot of their ideas are
completely ridiculous and
it they're hoping that these
theories are right and I want the most
sexy and ridiculous option to be real.
Has there been any video of or witnesses
showing of the birds falling like,
hey, why are all these birds? I do
not think so. I don't think anybody,
just some kind of graffiti prank that p
kids or never even having them on over
miles there you don't understand. These
are like thousands of birds over miles,
that very same species over and
over again. Something happened.
He's birds in the air and it was either
they were poisoned or they're hit by
hail. Hail is possibility.
Some people saw fireworks,
scared them and they slammed into things.
But that doesn't make any dead
birds is the next crop circle.
We just don't know yet.
But what I was saying is look at all
the different shit that's going down.
All these birds done,
all these fish dying,
all the water leaking of the oil leaking
into the ocean, all the, uh, the, the,
the floods that are going on right now
in, in Australia. I mean, they're like,
it's like the size of Europe is underwater
in Australia. I mean, it's incredible.
And now the latest thing is the scientists
are saying that there's a possibility
of some gigantic superstorm that could
hit Los Angeles or get to hit California.
And that literally 25% of all the
houses are going to be flooded in room.
They don't know.
They're trying to figure it out,
but they're saying because of
all the hot weather that, well,
this is what it says con cal guess is
that it will never happen. Yeah. Yeah.
That's a good guess. But apparently it's
happened. US Geological Survey. Uh, they,
they've, they've, they've studied that
the dates to 12, four, four 46, you know,
when they'd done like core samples
and the earth, uh, 1029, 14, 18, 16,
oh five was the last time it happened.
So it happens every few hundred years.
They have these, you know, you
know, it could be 800 years.
They have these gigantic superstorms
and what they're talking about,
the superstorms raining for 40 days,
dumping 10 feet of water and this is all
possible and they're saying the storm
would be goaded on by an atmospheric
river that would move water at the same
time rate as 50 Mississippi's discharging
water into the Gulf of Mexico,
into the clouds coming through us.
It just would be just a massive
amount of water pouring notion.
Let it go inland.
Shit that we couldn't even wrap our head
around there saying that literally it
would be like,
you know,
it would be like the same
category as a gigantic earthquake.
I want a boat on a boat.
I don't think a boat we'll help you
do if you're way up here. But Dude,
a boat is going to,
the water's gonna come over the top,
but smash on top of you
and crush your head.
I don't think a boat's going to help pour
down. I Dunno. I mean, I'm [inaudible].
We talked to me.
Obviously this never happened in
recorded human history that we know of.
You know, that we don't have any
representations of what it was like,
but I think that it's, I mean, if they're,
they're really telling you that it's going
to come in 40 days in dump 10 feet of
water and that's insane.
The rate of 50 Mississippi rivers
discharging water into the Gulf of Mexico,
pouring down on the state.
That's incredible.
They're talking about 125 mile
an hour winds, landslides.
Think about all those guns. Goofy
houses are all gone about, happens.
All those Laurel Canyon houses that
are on still early days of rain. Yeah,
that's a wrap. Bitches. Like
a few years ago, a bunch of
them, too much rain. Right?
And then like six houses fell down.
Remember Malibu Laurel too.
Mad mealtime, multibillion dollar
houses at mill million. Excuse me.
It looks seven, $8 million
houses in Malibu. Just sinking
big chunks of the hill.
Broke off away from their pipes were
sticking out, electricity sparks and shit.
And then,
I mean they had all this video of these
things sliding down the hills like you
do your, you can't make a house on
the side of a fucking hill like that.
That ain't cool. I know you want a
nice view, but you're being ridiculous.
Like you just totally rolling
the dice with Mother Nature.
How fucking awesome is this?
Whether it was 84 here in short,
five fucking love.
Twitter's from people in Calgary.
Yesterday was 30 below with the windchill
factor use or just got back from
Chicago, said hadn't see daylight in four
days. Yeah, it was snowing and overcast.
Yeah, it gets gray and then you've got
to take your jacket off here. Yeah.
See seasonal affective disorder.
That's a real shit. You know, you're,
you're not happy when it's
gray all the time. That's care.
What you say about California still shit.
This weather is good the most.
The best thing about California is the
sun and that's why they have those lights
that you didn't even have this nightstand
lights where it just gives you a
simulation of the sun will do. That's
why. That's why Colorado so fucking dope.
Colorado has sun 250 to 300 days a year,
like they have very few overcast days,
so even though it's cold, it's sunny.
That's what we need,
man. It's not the cold.
It's so bad because when it's cold out
yet sucks to drive. But you know what man,
you put some fucking clothes on.
You put a warm coat on gloves.
When it's sunny out and it's cold,
it's like, whoa, it's cold out here.
But you're still smiling.
You can go out with your friends and go
snowboarding and shit and go fuck around.
When it's Boston, Boston winters
brow, they would just be like, God,
when is it going to end?
It's like you were being pissed on so
you've been held down and pissed on it.
You just have to deal with it.
Okay. When are you gonna let me up.
Still sucks dealing with snow in
general though. I hate fucking snow.
I want to punch it smells bad. Ice
is worse. Icy Rain is the worst.
The worst is when it's like 31 degrees.
That's scary shit cause it rains and it
turns to ice the next morning and the
rains on top three in the morning.
It's so bad. When I was in high school,
me and my buddy,
uh,
my sister's boyfriend sat on top of
the garage and just watch these cars
slamming,
knew each other because our whole street
was covered in ice and we lived on a
hill. So we just sat, we drank beer and
we sat on the roof and it was a show.
We were just watching guys slide down
and the cop cars to cop car came down
slight. We told him he called
the cops. Yeah, yeah, we'll
be right there. You know,
they came, they came. Dummies didn't
listen. Came Downhill. I tell him,
you better go uphill because if you do,
if you go downhill,
you're not gonna be able
to stop. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Fucking don't tell me what to do.
Fucking queer attacking each other,
but no one's ever learning and changing
their behavior. Well, it's still dull.
They're not introspective at all.
Talk Shit on Boston,
but still one of the
best places to have fun.
It's one of the best places to do shows.
It's a fucking, it's a great town.
I just don't want to live there anymore.
I can't deal with the winters,
but the people are fucking phenomenal.
They're fun.
There's like a certain
energy that they have.
There's a certain like they're like a zest
for life. You know when you, when you,
you have to fucking walk home in the cold
and you have to deal with that kind of
shit. You deal with those kinds
of, that kind of weather, if any,
having donors go there. Yeah. It's
not the best way to describe it.
I imagine it as like the
downstairs in titanic,
people dancing and having a great
old time, like a poverty thing.
There's a lot of rich people in Boston.
It's just that there's a certain amount
of no nonsense in a place where it gets
zero degrees for a month.
You know? It's that wicked,
but it's different than like Montreal.
It's like, why is no one from Vermont,
so like assholes? Who you, well,
Vermont is like Super Hippie, liberal,
grateful dead California to
Ben and Jerry's ice cream.
It's a beautiful state to man. God,
I, I used to do gigs in Vermont.
I would drive up to Burlington and just
be driving and I would just be trying to
think of how I can live here.
I'd be like 21 years old and
I would be in my car going,
is there a way that I could
figure out how to live here?
Because this is how I want to live,
man.
I want to live where there's like a river
by my house and it's like green grass
and there's woods and it's
like it's healthy. When I,
when I drive around La as like, all right,
this is where I have to live, right?
I'm in my car,
I'm on this fucking monstrous freeway
that's six lanes on each side and every
one of those jams solid. No one can
move. I don't want to live like that.
You want to take a dirt road and pass
somebody on the left? I want to beat,
I want peace.
I just went to bathrooms are tired of how
my parents tried to send it to Vermont.
A camp, learning retards for learning
disabilities. What was wrong with you?
Learning disability? What kind of learning
disabilities? Uh, underachieving, uh,
son of a middle class family,
but it's not read a really up,
you don't have a learning disability. You
were probably just bored, Huh? Um, yeah,
they say that.
But that's why I think we've learned
that there was a psychological block,
probably something like that where it
wouldn't let you get into what you're
doing.
It's so hard when you have a troubled
childhood to be good at school because you
know, I had a troubled childhood and you
just don't want to concentrate on what
they're teaching you.
You're,
you're just trying to figure out the
whole world around you and how to,
how to navigate through it.
Cool people and yeah,
just trying figure out how to not get
picked on and how to fucking get home
without, you know, having no
fear for your life. Like, which,
what your kids do I have to avoid, where
do I have to go and all that shit. It's,
they're very difficult to concentrate
on us history. Like how was this?
The shit ain't affecting me. You
know? I just like watching TV.
I was kind of lucky because I hung out
with the Asian kid and I went thought he
knew karate. So really trying
to fuck his sister, his sister,
just the Asian girl. It was an Asian
girl that wasn't related. Yeah,
they weren't two different families and
different families. They try to hook up.
No,
I think they hated each other cause I
think one was Japanese and moment or with
Korean, Koreans and
Japanese. The Japanese,
because of all the robots do the
rape and Nam King. There's a,
there's a crazy documentary that
I watched is very disturbing.
Some of the sheets the
Japanese did to the Chinese,
like genocidal gave in Cardinia
potholes in babies and fucked them.
Ah, yeah, like really dark, dark,
dark shit or just they just didn't
respect them as as people. No,
they killed systematically tortured them
and did all kinds of crazy shit man.
It's a, it's a really, really disturbing
documentary. It was a documented this.
I have it. If you want to watch
it we can watch it. It's not, um,
it wasn't released like I
had to buy it from some,
some a library somewhere actually had
like rented and then not bring it back to
you. One of those things. Yeah, just
pay the fine so that you can get it.
I couldn't get it anywhere else and
it's a really creepy and there's,
there's a bunch of shit on it online.
If you could read about it.
I don't know the,
it's like this is all like my friend
Rupert who was a director of your factor.
He,
he turned me onto this many,
many years ago and I got into it back
then and it was so disturbing that I
forgot a lot of the particulars, so I'm
not going to, you know, I can't quote it,
but if you,
if you're into genocide and into reading
up about how fucking cruel people can
pay, it's the genocide dude. I mean, a lot
of people are into finding out how deep,
how
long walks in the park.
They were talking about
this a few weeks ago at,
somebody found it in his
own lawn and is a yard sale.
They found a human skin lamp from the
Holocaust and he sold it for 30 bucks is
right, bought it, and then
took it to his friend,
get thousand dollars got tested there
like it is humans can dish. It was so old,
they couldn't tell what race it had come
from. Wow. That's true. The Holocaust.
Holy Shit.
Like this had been someone's skin
and now it's adorning a lamp.
Uh, it's crazy. The judge,
that was not that long ago. No,
there are people still alive. Yeah. A
lot of them. Lot of people, you know,
there was, I watched the documentary
on the moon landing, Swanson,
there was this guy who was a, uh, a
consequent cost Treatian camp survivor,
and he had his tattoos and he was talking
about Wernher von Braun that Wernher
von Braun ran a rocket factory in
Brazil, or excuse me, in Berlin.
What a lot of people don't realize
that the guy was the head of NASA,
Wernher von Braun was a serious Nazi
because that guy was alive today.
He would be the Simon Wiesenthal Center
said they would prosecute him for crimes
against humanity.
He used to hang the five slowest Jews in
front of his factory in Berlin. Anytime,
you know, people are slow, hang them,
hang them in front of everybody else.
So everybody would walk through and see
what the fuck was going on. Look, look,
these are these guys
you used to work with.
Now they're hanging in front of the
fucking door, slow go to work. I mean,
it's dark, dark, dark shit.
And this guy with his tattoo from the
Holocaust was talking about how he
remembers very clearly
seeing Wernher von Braun.
They would come in with suits and they
know I'll be working and they would come
in and inspect the work and walk around
people and he'd fucking hang people
hanging right in front of
people. You know? And this was a,
there's a thing called
operation paperclip. They
were all brought over here.
All the Nazi scientists.
Yeah, that's what it's called.
They were all brought over here to run
NASA in the United States had like dog
shit for a rocket program before
Wernher von Braun came over.
He was a super genius.
I feel like it's easy to like dehumanize
that moment when you say like, oh,
he used to hang people. But if you imagine
it from the person's point of view,
like you're just taking a ranch or
something and someone grabs you and you're
just screaming to like,
please don't, don't.
And they didn't put it around your neck.
All right.
And how many people do we know that are
just lazy as fuck and would slack off
and not, not made workers.
Yeah, me too. You know?
I mean until someone died and
then I was like, all right,
I'm going to need to get through this.
You know,
and then you know the of children and
your children are being held captive to
your whole family is being held
captive. I mean, it's really,
really scary to think that that was not
that long ago and that while this is
going on, it was so much more
important for us to win the space race.
They were like, yeah, Wernher von
Braun, Mr Nancy, come on over here.
Get on over here buddy.
Don't worry about all that other shit.
You get over the and whatever,
whatever, whatever, up race or race.
No one's going to know.
They're not going to know your Wernher von
Braun from NASA. Don't sweat it, buddy.
We're all good now.
It's all groovy.
That's like what your friend is like
really douchey. Didn't like just look,
just don't bring it up. Let's just go.
Just leave this fucking guy though. Man.
This documentary was so intense when
he would chose Tattoo and he would talk
about seeing Wernher von Braun and
talk about, you know, the, you know,
how they would hang people
in the front of the factory.
Like this shit is never leaving
that guy's brain. You know,
that guy was a slave for a while and
here now he was living in Miami and you
know,
relaxing his entire retirement years away.
But there was a point in that guy's
life where he lived in utter terror
surrounded by monsters.
Like the goddamned star wars episode.
The storm troopers would come in
and they would just, you know,
a lot of people he knew were dead.
That's some scary shit.
Think that people are willing to
go that and they go that, you know,
relatively easily. You know, it's
not, it's not like, you know,
that's hard to get people to do. It's
happened many times. I mean, it is hard,
but it's happened many, many
times throughout history
of Pol Pot with, you know,
so many different cases of genocide.
The Stalin,
I mean all these different examples
all around the world. Liberia, yeah.
So many all around the world. I mean,
look what's going on in Iraq. I mean,
if you talk about the numbers
in Iraq, supposedly, uh,
according to many credible sources,
a million civilians have died since
2002 or 2003, whenever we invaded.
I'm not doing it in a million a million.
Wrap your brain around that, you know,
wrap your brain around that.
That's some crazy shit.
Do you remember that old footage of the,
um,
the guys on tanks and they were listening
to death metal and they were fucking,
they were shooting, they showed like
what it's like to be over there in Iraq.
Remember that's just the x's
eliminate them. Yeah. These guys,
they were listening to music.
They were listening to like crazy,
like metal music while they
were shooting people in Iraq.
And I remember it was a,
it was a video and you know,
they were interviewing these guys
and what's it like? It was, you know,
they're smoking cigarettes in their real
young and it's like so surreal to them.
Yeah. But it doesn't even seem
real. Apparently. This is all, um,
the wiki leaks put that out too.
Oh yeah. That was the first one.
We're missing something. I
didn't know that man. Yeah,
I did not know that was the first
thing when they got some friendly fire
situation. See somebody kill talking
about, it's called collateral murder.
That's a video that they released.
That was the start of all this wiki leaks.
This shit was way before that.
A few years before that. Yeah.
They've been involved for a long
time release and shit. I did.
I didn't know that they had been around
as long as it had been around that a
sandwich dude. It's so fucking
interesting. It's fascinating.
But seems so douchey.
Like when you read, did you read his
online dating profile? No. Oh my God.
He's just,
just so douchey.
Just like it comes through the screen
and gets your fingers greasy. Really.
Like, you know what he's talking
about? Like you know, who does it,
what does he want to meet people for
Friendship for, you know, whatever.
And it's like, it's just
like, it's the, first of all,
literally it is impossible to make an
online dating profile and not come off
Douchey. It's not possible. It
is not talk yourself up. Right.
You have to talk yourself up and you have
to lie about what you're looking for.
What are you looking for?
I'm looking for some really easy pussy
from a hot girl is not going to ask too
many questions where it's not going to
get crazy and you're never going to be
mad at me cause I don't want to be with
you anymore. Can I get that? No, no.
And so everybody's got this whole thing.
I'm looking for romance.
I mean even if you're not, you know,
so it's impossible to, you know,
I'm outgoing but I, you know, I'm,
I'm friendly to a fault and look for the
real me. You'll be pleasantly surprised.
Oh good.
Like what you find is someone,
she should make a profile and just overdo.
Sure.
We're doing almost like Brody
Stevens that where it's like,
like a becomes a comedy set. Scott,
I have a couple out there somewhere.
Do you have dating? Probably
hilarious. Big will after a fiance,
the seven year relationship ended.
I went through a,
like a or I have been single in
eight years or so, seven years.
I have no idea what to do,
so I got into the online thing because
it was before Facebook and Myspace,
you know?
Really,
so it's just making a my space profile
pretty much just the craziest thing.
What you did is you want in the last
like fucking 70 pounds or something.
What did you lose? How much do you
lose? I got 70 70 pounds, 70 pounds.
I remember when you got
super giant like Smurf,
like yeah dude,
you couldn't walk straight.
Your legs would rub in the middle. You'd
have to, you'd have to, Ralphie may at.
You'd have to circle your legs on the
outside and then bring them back in the
front or it's impression,
a good impression.
He's got the worst impressions of
anyone I've ever heard of. Yeah.
It's not a good impact. Maybe. At
least I don't do it. It's amazing.
It's amazing how awesome they are.
Gizmo from Gremlin's singing.
It's pretty good. That's
old school geek. Cool.
How am I doing it? Mock why? That was
a great your mind. No, I loved it.
I loved it when they got
wet turn monsters and
shit. Cause that what happened? They
got started and then they become evil.
It's so crazy.
Like they're so cute when they're little
tiny things and then turned into key
for school. You get them wet? Yeah.
What? Or feed him after midnight. Oh,
feed them after midnight. That was all
a metaphor for treating women, isn't it?
You can't get them alcohol after midnight
because it will become crazy animals.
They we come horse bitches. You can't
deal with them bitches, man. Bitches.
It ain't about that Brian.
Man. Don't become a woman
hater. Okay, just kidding. No,
that's from a movie that's from like
say anything or said, Oh really?
I didn't know that you, um,
are you worried about becoming
a woman? Hear me? Yeah.
Oh No, absolutely. Absolutely. No worries.
Fuck no chicks don't have to worry. Sweet.
Brian will never go away. No, I'm
a crazy hater. You're crazy heater.
Is that what it is? Did
you take crazy? Yeah.
I just need to start changing
my go to yoga classes,
brow and pizza on centered
girls with loose sweat pants.
You know what I'm talking about?
Joe Rogen downward facing dog
all up in this bitch. Yeah,
I heard that's the best place though
to actually hit head on my man.
Mr. Sing it girls buttholes all day.
And then you see how flexible and yeah.
Sexy their bodies,
man hope finger of it in terms of that
and see if they fart when they get stuck
in weird positions at saddle ranch when
they have some inviting the bowl on.
Super slow. Some hot girl, super
slow riding. It was like, oh my God.
All the guys were looking at trying not
to look like they are looking. Yeah,
it's just hot. Yeah. There's a,
there's a some strange connection
between his imagine there.
It's you under the right.
I saw Tipco at the other day.
Always waiting for that and a bull riding.
Yeah, it was black chick, black chicks,
tit.
Nice black chicks on a bull ride.
This just letting me know I need some
white Dick Krakow. Yeah, let's get it on
Brian.
Um,
have you considered maybe trying some
black checks out since he's white chicks?
I, yeah, we've talked about this
and I, I have a certain, yeah,
I'm totally going to go for
it. Hey, I would go for it,
but it has to be a certain
kind of a certain kind of
black check. Not a big one.
Not the one that like if you just don't
squint your eyes and imagine them with
short hair that they're
a guy. Oh, by the way,
have you seen pictures of
Little Kim? Yeah. Oh my God.
Google Little Kim photos.
Show it to Ari.
She did crazy plastic
surgery and she became like,
she looks like a Vietnamese woman.
Lil Kim Little Kim is dude,
it's really hard to look at.
Chief really, really fucked up.
Like really bad. It's almost like
Steven Tyler. Yeah. He looks like a bat.
Boom man. Look, go back up to that. Yeah.
Look at that. He looks like a bat. Boom.
His whole bottom of his
lip thing is jutting out.
I bet he gets stuck on me and cock.
Oh, you'd know what those big fat lips.
Yeah.
Ooh,
that's a football player,
I think.
Isn't it weird how the doctors come out
in scrubs as if they just came from the
hospital? That guy. Why don't
you just Google the actual image?
It's on the second page.
Yeah,
it's really crazy. You got to
see it. They don't just have it.
Can you just Google images? What do you
do when you're scrolling? Like my mom,
this is how my mind, Dark
Ages. I'll find you. Mine.
You're just always in a hurry.
Why are you always in a hurry?
My mother became Jewish chickson name.
It's the most annoying impression you
could do. Have a mother, little Kim,
little Kim, l I. L little Kim photos,
plastic surgery. What the fuck?
Type all that out and here we go. Bam.
Look at her on the right kind of crazy.
It kind of looks like it might be makeup.
She was on Jackson. I don't know Bro.
That's coming off. What?
She has the cat eye.
I look at her nose man. Other
ones, their before and after.
She looks a little like Janet
Jackson. If there's a way worse, Bro.
I think way worse. Janet Jackson. Well,
I haven't seen Janet Jackson recently,
but for the longest time she kept
it together. See before and after.
Let's see that one on the top was
it? That's her. Look at that dude.
She's hot there. It's already
a little Asian. Huh? Whoa.
Look at the difference that is monstrous.
That it's terrifying.
And then it was kind of looks
the same though. You said about
people, man, where they, they just
start fucking changing their face.
That's so scary. Well, I can, I can
totally relate to that. Like having to,
haven't done, not what tattoos
but with having done, um,
hair transplants because a
dunk doing hair transplants,
like I was losing my hair and I was
like, well, how do I stop this man?
Is there a way to stop it?
I don't want to wear a fucking
wig and I want to be bald. Like,
how do I stop this?
So then a friend of mine had gotten hair
transplants and he had me convinced,
he's like, dude, just getting
her to transfer the team.
They take it from the back.
They put it the front,
like you do it as you're losing your hair
and you can keep your hair. I'm like,
oh, okay, cool. And so I did it and
right after I did it I felt like, oh,
now you have this stupid scar
in the back of your head.
Didn't they tell you about the scar?
That all I knew about the stupid
scar but I didn't think about it.
You don't need to think about ads in the
back of the head was going to notice,
you know, you think everything's
going to turn out normal and be fine.
And then I wanted to do
another one to correct it.
So I did another one and it looks still
looks like shit now the scar in the back
of my head is bigger and after a while,
you know,
it's like you can get roped into like
I know a guy who um, uh, he does, he's,
he passed away a few years ago,
but he was obsessed with plastic surgery
and he was a nice guy and he's in show
business and he had done a
bunch of different things
to the point where his face
look weird and his, he had peck implants
and he had a bunch of hair transplants.
You just start,
you start fucking with your appearance
like that and it becomes like a up,
it becomes like a
pathology. Yeah. You like,
you get sick like [inaudible] who have
issues that two people do the same thing.
Yeah. Yeah. Two, three, four.
Well, I shouldn't say that.
I mean both of my arms or
sleeved, but I'm stopping. I mean,
I don't have a problem.
I just felt like when I did the one,
I felt like I was on balanced and then
I really had an idea for the second one
that I wanted to do and I'm like, I
don't mind having two sleeves of tattoos.
It's not like I'm getting them on
my fucking face or anything crazy.
Which speaking of does something like,
there's a line where you're not supposed
to tattoo and your face is that line
above you see the Kushi Lane. Have
you seen Gucci Mane? Have you seen it?
You haven't seen Gucci Mane.
Gucci. You type up Gucci Mane.
Face Tattoo, get ready for this.
Gucci Mane is a rapper. Okay.
And he got a face tattoo and
his face tattoo is an ice cream.
Cassava,
I saw the,
it says three scoops of ice cream on it
and it says burr. That's it. I'm thought,
I know it's top left. Top Top. That's not
that. There we go. Yeah, that's the image.
Click on that. Folks
online. You, you, you,
you have to see this
if you haven't already,
most of the Internet already has seen
it, but it's like, it's clear madness.
I mean,
he gets released from a mental institution
and then he has an ice cream cone
tattooed on his face. This
guy out of war, if you,
it's like it's live like clinger,
right?
It's my horrible,
I'll just keep saying I'm a cross dresser
until they let me out and me more.
It was, I can't match. Goes on forever.
Check Brian's tattooed or Brian's tattoo.
He got it from a guy who
was learning how to Tattoo,
so we talked to them for [inaudible]
school. No good cheap shit.
This chick that w that worked for me
when I was a manager of movie theater.
She's like, I want to be a tattoo artist.
My Ha, my boyfriend owns a tattoo studio.
He's been trying to
teach me on cantaloupes.
Would you like to be my first person?
It will be free. I was like, sure,
why not cantaloupes? You know you're
supposed to practice on pig ears and shit.
That's just relax on pigskin similar to
humans scam, but it's an art form man.
Like,
you know my boy Aaron Dellavedova,
my buddy from a crew tattoo who does my
stuff, he totally offered to to fix it.
It's kind of funny story now.
Like I was the other day,
I was just laying in bed and I worked on
this movie called a better way to die a
long time ago and my job was to do like,
all right this,
you need to make this a tag,
this whole area, like all
these cars, all these walls,
you need to make it little at graffiti.
Like it's a gang ridden
a alley in Chicago. Yeah,
I was doing said what?
Fuck you become so interested in this.
So that was a chick I'd be
showing to you right now.
How fast it was done so many things.
It was like three days after I got
this tattoo and I'm like, dude,
I'm just going to put my
fucking tattoo everywhere.
So I just sprayed my tattoo on the walls,
on the cars and that put nine
inch nails and a couple of places.
But then I did all these like my tattoos
and so the other day I'm just sitting
there watching it and then it
was like, good. I'm like, Oh,
this is a movie I worked
on. And it was like, wow,
there's my waterfall tattoo
everywhere. I was like, that's,
I just changed that scene into like the
faggy ass gang scene everywhere by the
way. You explain to people what
waterfall tattoo ones cause they don't,
well I got,
I went and got this free tattoo or
whatever and I looked in the book and then
the couple of things I liked
were like Egyptian turtles and,
and I saw it. I was like into Asian
girls at that time or whatever.
So I got an are in Chinese and they
put it together and I said I also like
Spiderman.
So they mixed the three up and it's like
Spiderman logo with a Chinese letter in
the middle. Hey, I'm,
you know that I have it as a new hire
primate tee shirts coming out yet. Yeah.
For folks who don't know,
if you go to higher primate,
higher-primate.com
that's my clothing line.
I actually have a clothing line now
called higher primate and it's real
low key.
I'm just kinda trying to figure it out
before I going to go commercial with it.
Yeah. That's all just t shirts. I'm
going to have fanny packs to stay strong.
Faggy pack date. Truong bitches
love annual packs coming back, son.
I've traveled a fair. Any artist
fears? Seen it. Brian seen it.
I'm not fucking around with his fanny
pack would be cool if you renamed it baggy
pack pack faggy packs. That's not bad.
That's a good idea, right? Why not, right,
right. It's not fancy. It's not fag hag
enough though. Pat, any pack. Anyway,
the point is, my point is with
these new t shirts, we could, uh,
I want to make that red band logo
with the, the explosion. The,
the suicide kitty suicide kitty.
Yeah. Let's turn that into a shirt.
I've got to do that. We'll sell
it. You know, we could just,
I'll have these guys make it for you.
You already have the thing.
So we have the company to make sure it's
now and we'll, uh, we'll sell it on.
We know what,
we'll just sit on red button,
red band.com because I know a lot of
people on the board asked about it.
I would wear that shit. Yeah, I like
it. It's kind of an inside thing,
like no one would even know what
the fuck that means. You know,
it's so funny as a, uh, I, those other
podcasts I did the death squad podcasts,
stitcher,
just put them on the radio and they kind
of like make a local thing like welcome
to the United States has like, did they,
they know that that's like a Hitler cat,
that Hitler who's covered with explosive,
explosive,
no suicide in his hand
for people don't know,
like what does his death squad thing.
This all happened when we
were on a opie and Anthony,
and this is like fucking
many years ago. Uh, we,
I came on to Opie and Anthony and uh,
I brought with me Eddie Bravo, uh,
Tait Fletcher.
And this was like right after Tate had
done the ultimate fighter and Tate was a
traveled on the road with us.
And Brian,
you came on to write and who
else was already, did you go,
you can walk about another time.
He came on a different time.
You came out of the time
when we roasted Jamie, uh,
saw that as a baby and the baby bird
that was that far off in another minute.
So we've done many, many times.
Anyway, we'd come in and you know,
Tate is such an imposing figure taters
this gigantic fucking hunk of a man and a
we'd walk in the room with,
you know,
everybody knows Eddie Bravo
is his Jujitsu master.
He just choked out horror
Gracie. And then, you know,
it's like so oop goes looking at Joe
Rogan's with the death squad and then it
became weeks, you know, just thought
it was so silly. You know, death squad.
We started calling ourselves
dusk squad. Yeah, I started,
actually, this is kind of,
it's kind of interesting. Back in the
day when podcasts were first made,
I started making little short Joe show
videos and then call them death squad.
And they were only available on
iTunes as a podcast video podcast.
I had had 12 of them or something like
that. Yeah. Those fucking old videos do.
Some of those were brilliant.
I went back and watched a couple of
those old desk squads that you did.
Some of those were fucking funny as
shit and some of the moments we captured
were so ridiculous. Getting mad at you
for about Ari Shaffir becoming a lawyer.
Okay.
There was a guy who was
insane and he said he was the Holy Spirit
and he needed help and he wanted to
somehow or another, he wanted me to
help him and, and then Ari got involved,
you know, you call a call. I got her
home. I was, I didn't have a spot.
It's like 1230 or something at the
store. So you, you had having this
whole argument. I had no idea. You're
just calling me like, hey listen,
I need you to be my lawyer.
I'm like, what? What do you
mean if you're my lawyer?
He's like, someone's gonna call you
and you got to be my Lord. I'm like,
what should I say? I'm like, Hey, I've got
another call here. Your mother, goodbye.
[inaudible] one of those dudes who,
you know,
if you got a friend who
was a standup comedian,
but he has got a wife and he's
got kids and he's got a day job,
he's got a lot of,
you can't count on that motherfucker.
He's not always down for the fund.
But I could call Ra should fear at
three o'clock in the morning. Ari,
I need you to represent me as my lawyer.
Are you comfortable with this? Uh,
because the background is
pretty high right now, but,
so anyway, go ahead. It's got called me
so he can take down the footage of you.
You said you have to call my lawyer to
take on this footage. It's very important.
If you want to take down the footage,
you're going to have to call my lawyer,
my lawyer, because this crazy
guy, he was completely nuts.
And in retrospect and you thought
was the Holy Spirit. Yeah,
I thought it was the Holy Spirit.
I forget a lot of other shit that he
said he was trying. He was gonna Sue,
John Edwards
psychic for being a false prophet.
And I remember going like, why should
we sue him? Like, why would you sue him?
He's like, this is a false prophet. He
was going to, but why you, you know?
He had a lot of interesting things to
say. Yeah, great. Back massage too.
I got him to give me power of attorney
over all his affairs verbally recorded it.
I don't know what I do. I
can get the recording. Yeah,
I did it and then he disappeared for
a while and then he came back. Right.
Sued me. How long ago did he
go to court court and sued me?
I forgot about that.
He sued me for millions of $18 million.
We get nervous at all.
Where you even a little bit,
well first I wrote this guy on
for like six months to a year.
Just kept until they got too annoying
and I was like, I'm bored. But yeah,
he sued me for big fig, a bad attorney.
I'm like, I represented you pro bono.
How many people are out there right now
who are looking to get mad at something
like,
that's real good fucking Dick.
Text somebody with mental
illness and make fun of them.
It's really funny fucking Shit.
Hope you drowned in a river of age that's
like obviously it's not a nice thing
to do, but it was fun anyway.
There's a guy was annoying.
He was annoying from the get go, which
is why we did this in the first place.
We couldn't get rid of them.
It's amazing.
How bad is it if you actually eat
toothpaste? Terrible for in Florida.
Really awful.
Yeah.
I mean it's not going to kill you
because like do you real toxic levels of
Florida.
I bet if you ate a whole
tube of toothpaste you could
probably get really sucked
up. Even like one drop to
go to the emergency room.
No names to faces or something like that.
They might say that just to cover
their ass cause I used to that we,
that was my go to thing and you know,
keep a tube of toothpaste and my car,
you know and just like eat
it [inaudible] something bad.
Don't do that man.
Well,
that was like when I was 16 about fluoride
in the drinking water and everybody
claims to know exactly.
By the way that sound you're hearing is
a shot at the volcano you ever comes to.
No, but where are the people dying?
Where is it happening? Interesting.
Where the interesting part
about it is that that is all a,
supposedly if you go online
and read the websites,
communists based on a Nazi shit,
the idea of keeping the people
a passive and keeping people
in their place and making sure
they're docile and easy to control,
and that was the idea of putting
fluoride in the water supply.
I highly doubt that's why it helps
your toy. Yeah, I think it's probably,
I don't know if it does help your t's.
I don't really know cause there's
a lot of things that say this. No,
that's not the case. What helps
your teeth is fucking cleaning him.
You fucking pigs now.
That's what's good for your teeth.
I use Tom's of Maine toothpaste and it
doesn't have fluoride in it for that shit.
There certain types of sweet berry
taste taste like you're eating chocolate
tastes like the shit I used when I lift
weights and I put chalk on my hands.
Do you think that maybe that toothpaste
is PR missing some thing that you,
no cavities. I haven't had
cavities in a law. Really. I'm,
I'm pretty good at brushing. That's
going the last time I went to the, um,
to the eye,
first of all I went like years without
any teeth cleaning and then I went to the
dentist and I didn't have any cabinet has
really surprised you got to do it dude.
If you fuck up like yeah,
learn, learn from my mistake.
I eat so many gummy bears.
Don't, I definitely have cavities and
you go to sleep right? You just crash.
That's not good.
Good morning.
And you got to clean your teeth because
your gums will receive to which,
which did happen to me. There was
an area where I had a a cap and um,
if you got a really clean around those
things, cause it's not like natural,
you know, you can get a lot of plaque
and then my gum is receding a little bit.
So then I had to get it really they
take gum from the back and put it in the
fall. It wasn't like that. It does.
They do do that though. It's really bad.
Or is there this great bit of a hair
transplant now because get them now,
not 25 years ago when they were terrible.
Now is when you get the procedure.
Even now, don't get it a ticket from me
folks. This is the way I describe it.
This is how stupid the idea of hair
transplants are. You're taking,
it's like taking people who are really
healthy and moving him to a neighborhood
where everyone's dying. Cause
that's what it's like. Cause they,
the hair that you have up on the top of
your head after you've transplant Harris,
the other hair's gonna fall out too.
So even though it looks okay at first,
like when I was on like news
radio is when I first got it done,
my hair looked fucking sport.
He just started Rogan.
Did you look at Rogan for a picture?
No, I was, I was thinking about doing it.
I don't really need it too bad because
I've always had high. We're now,
but the problem is is if you look
at Rogaine, it only does the middle.
No, no, no. Broken. Does the back corner.
Oh No, no, no, no. It does everything.
It was a study that they did in the
study they did was on the vertex of the
scalp and the idea was that
you can't prove you'd have to,
it would have to go and spend millions
and millions of dollars and I studied to
show the reason why it works on this,
the reason why it works at all is it
increases circulation to the area so it
makes your hair grow.
It will work everywhere in your scalp.
It doesn't just work in
the back of your head. Yes,
especially Propecia and Rogaine. Same
thing, but most people have bald spots.
In the back of the head and he had a
concentrate on one area of the head cause
they needed like a patch, you know that
they would prove that it worked there.
So they proved that it worked in the
back of your head and so they just went
with it.
It proven to grow hair good enough.
They don't have to show you that it works.
It's not flowing to grow in the front.
But it's not just writer. But he died.
No, it does. It's, it's the way it works.
Shift Minoxidil Minoxidil when they
first made it was a high blood pressure
medication.
See, I swear to God, even like on
Amazon or on their own advertising,
it says this is the
area. Exactly. They have
to because that was the study
scientifically proven to wow. Yeah.
See they made the study.
Right. I see what I'm saying.
That's kind of weird that
they have to do that though.
And they couldn't say and it might
work on the other side. Yeah, no,
they don't want to do that. They want
to, you can't say anything by that ghost.
This is, we don't look good here.
Sucking out of plastic bags,
sucking missed out of bags. You
know, this does not look like a,
like something a healthy person.
When did your thing it's done.
I've got to go soon.
Okay, well let's end this fucking crazy
thing. You put a couple shows. Yeah.
Vegas February 4th yeah. We're doing
a bunch of shows together. Ari.
Fear is coming to for the next one
is actually, um, West Palm Beach.
We're doing the Improv in West Palm Beach,
the 28th,
29th and 30th West Palm Beach,
Florida.
So it be the young and
talented Mr Rsu fear.
And that is a dope fucking club.
It's gigantic.
It's like 650 50 seats. It's a,
it's awesome. So that's a, yeah,
the 28th,
29th and 30th and then we're also
doing February 4th at the Mandalay Bay
theater. The big spot. Who's the
new one? How many seats is it?
It's like 2000 and this would be the
biggest show I've ever done. Yeah,
it's pretty well, I think in Canada
we did some bigger than that.
Everybody was behind us. That
was, that was a few thousand.
That was nuts. That was a
Calgary. Calgary was crazy.
We did a bunch of shows up that you
missed the Toronto. Toronto was shit.
I'm trying to do my special in Toronto,
but I'm having a hard
time getting a venue.
It's in April and a lot of these
things are booked in advance.
But if I get a get a venue,
a good venue,
I want to do this special in
April in Toronto, Toronto.
I recorded myself that a,
a couple of different places and I've
got an hour and 15 minutes a new shit.
So that's a enough where I can widdle
it down to what I want for like a 44
minute. What are you
playing music for? Prime.
We told you you can't play music unless
I made this song and you make a song.
You're so multitalented wait a minute.
You make newsletters and,
and you're a stalker and bang hot
chicks and you, you do set design.
And I hear you're doing standup
comedy when you perform it again,
uh, tonight, uh,
going to sounds and then big
fish and Glendale and I'm
hosting sales comedy club.
If, unless I'm going with
you do a Florida the 30th.
Yeah, that's, that's going to be the
shit. Do you want to come to Florida?
It's up to you. Do, do you wanna I would
love to go to Florida. Itar like Florida.
I love Florida. We'll hook it up. Um, so
third is my next story teller show. Yeah.
Where are these storytellers shows
that people can't see in San Francisco.
But you might be able to go right down
in the front at the purple and that are
sold out. I'm so glad about are
gone. That's one. It's called um, uh,
thicker than water. And when is this
all about families this weekend.
Friday and Saturday night. Yeah. And
then the next one is brain on drugs.
Just all drugstores nine. These are
both nice. Damn. These sounds good dude.
You sound really good. If people don't
know our has been doing this thing.
You've been doing it for about
a year now and it's really cool.
And what it is is he does like
a standup show but it's not,
they don't talk about,
because they don't do like set
up punchline set up punchline.
It's mostly like really funny stories
because a lot of sort of like,
you know like podcast stories. I've got a
lot of the, the funnier podcast stories,
you know, and Adam Carolla show or in
any of the other ones. It's like, it's,
they're not like a setup punchline.
It's can't like do home in front of
a comedy audience where they expect a
certain like rhythm but it's,
it can be slower.
It's more like Annie Hall
as a comedy where it's like,
it was good right now as huge
laugh, more involved, you know,
and you're going to see a comedy movie,
right?
If you're going to see a comedy movie,
it's not like always funny. Always funny.
Like they have to set up
a lot of what's funny.
And it was like just a lot of
spots where there's, you know,
you're not laughing for 10 15 minutes
but on stage it's got to be set up.
Punchline, punchline, set up punchline.
But the what you're doing is like you,
you're, you're making these guys, you're
giving them like a in a picture to venue.
Yeah.
Jellies were fucking spectacular man.
Your story of when you went to a strip
club in Alabama with, what's his name?
Mark Coleman. Yeah. That's like a perfect
like crazy story. Yeah, that's a PR. Yeah.
Yeah, there's exactly, I tried to do that
one for with comedy, like do it on stage,
but I had to punch it up too much.
I had to add a bunch of shit
to it and like shorter. Yeah.
I added combined two different
scenarios for crushers.
Tells the best story of all time.
The Tracy Morgan style.
He's supposed to come on tomorrow.
I got to, he lands today though.
I got a fucking good,
yeah, it's Tracy Morgan.
Is that the heart of a million
great stories. It's good to know.
There's dudes like that out there man.
When I see a guy like Joe Diaz
or a garlic, Tracy Morgan,
I just want to just shake their hand
and say thank you. Thank you for,
thank you for rocking it.
Mason just going out there and realizing,
man ain't know, nobody knows how the
fuck this thing works. Just go crazy.
You know, having a guy like Joe d as
in your life do well, do you wonders?
You know? I think he's Comedians for
real. He's like having him around you,
it like makes you funnier.
I really believe you're in a relaxed
when you kidnap someone. All right. Yeah.
Not only that, he's just, he's show,
I don't give a fuck that he makes things
more Cheley and more fun. It just,
it's more fun. Like Joe, I
always tell Joey like whenever
every special I've done,
and this is one of the things that I,
one of the reasons why I've thought
about not doing it in Toronto,
the number one reason
is I can't get Joey up.
Can't get up there with him
with aggravated kidnapping
and the Columbus that
places the bomb.
It was the bomb.
But what I'm trying to do is I'm trying
to do somewhere that I haven't done and
I really love Toronto. And uh, my,
my last show in Toronto sold out
like months in advance. It was crazy.
Like I got so much love and Toronto and
if the show was so much fun, I was like,
this would be a great place to do my shit.
And it's not like I've done it a bunch
of times where they've seen my material
over and over again. It's oversaturated
and you know, pretty much everything on,
I mean,
everything I'm doing in my sets these
days is all shit that wasn't on my old
stuff and saw all that stuff
has been phased out and
it's all straight new stuff.
So most people that I'm
running into on the road,
unless they get on youtube all the time,
they don't know the material. So to me,
Toronto is like the perfect spot. You
know, it's like they're, they're cool,
they're smart or enthusiastic. It's a fun
city. But I don't know if I could do it.
I'm going to have to find out.
We still haven't figured out if they get
the venue, you know, and then you know,
there's also a can't bring Joey. Oh yeah.
So I wonder if you can get them, eh,
maybe, maybe not getting up there.
He, he told me he was going to do,
we had some gigs in my truck was
Joe Rogan was the one I'm gonna do.
I'm flying to buffalo from Buffalo.
My friend Mikey statue. Yoni.
He's going to fucking drive me up there.
He goes.
He's going to drop off some
heroin. Halfway on the web
is a drop by the bridge.
It's a perfect time. Yeah. He would
always have some fucking crazy plan.
He had some crazy plan to
sneak in to do gigs. Wow. Yeah.
He wasn't fucking around either. He was
dead serious and he would do it. He,
those crazy stories are
really, they're all fucking
happen. Yeah. They're all real.
They're all real. When you've hung
around with Joey, as long as we have,
and still Joey to this day,
still completely unpredictable.
Like he was supposed to do Brian
show last Sunday at south and gone.
He just disappeared. It was watching
the mechanic earlier, the old one,
Charles Bronson,
Bronson,
he's upset and new ones coming
out this fucking Jason Dayton.
What the fuck's his name? Get the fuck
Outta here. Charles Bronson Cock sucker.
He's like angry or fuck you want man.
And who was the dude that played Charles
Bronson's protege? I don't the real one.
Who's the, yeah, the famous guy
that became a really nutty, uh, he,
he became like the biggest
drunk in Hollywood.
He was like super handsome and young
and devastating or no, no, no, no. He's,
you know,
he's on celebrity rehab right now and
he's a source of awesome entertainment.
If you haven't been watching your work,
I don't remember the guy's name.
It's like a three word name hold on.
And the mechanic
dog Ronson. That's the new ones
coming out real soon. Yeah.
That's just coming up. It's the Cap Jan
Michael, Vince is not ever hearing about,
and he was like this,
you know,
this fucking studly looking all
American super handsome actor movie star
character. And he, um,
he went and lost his fucking marbles
and became a huge drop just second right
there. Yeah, yeah.
I remember we've done these interviews
with them now and he's just a stuttering
fucking retard. I love
that. Isn't it weird math it
when you,
you know when you run into people like
at the store or something like that that
have hit the rocks to Kravitz
has gone completely down.
It's like he's burned out. What happened?
He's just like, it's like the, the drugs,
whatever it just to something was
in his brain is fucked up. He just,
he can't talk to me. A normal human
being and just fills you with sadness.
Being around him. He's just like, you
can't carry a normal conversation.
He starts midway through a conversation.
You can't leave. He wasn't always like,
no. I remember her like seven, eight
years ago. It was like a normal guy.
Normal little beaten down, but
still fall. It'll beaten down.
But I had some fun conversations with him.
So friendly and nice and now it's like,
so what happened?
I think the stuff caught up,
drugs or whatever he was doing,
that's my guess is it doesn't
get done eventually caught up.
I don't think it does anymore,
but I think it eventually,
I don't know that many people that have
totally cooked their brain with drugs.
Huh.
Do you know how many people do you know
that have cooked their brand with drugs?
Do you know anybody? I know I know a
couple of you right now that, uh, yeah.
So how many people would you guess you
know that like, absolutely like started,
that's what I would guess
that they looked, they looked
like you had done that.
Uh, at least one and two
and probably, I don't know,
there's probably another one, but I know
to have that could think of right now.
Did I have to tell you Brian Cowen
story about the girl who used to date,
listen to this shit up burned out.
There was a girl that
Brian Count dated and uh,
she was Khorasan the moment I met
her, I go, dude, I go listen to me.
I know you don't like to believe this.
I can smell crazy people. Okay, I go in,
this bitch stinks. This bitch is nuts.
Like all I is, meet her. I keep right.
It's ridiculous assumption on my part
just to be able to take this chance.
But all my spidey senses was like, Whoa,
what's going on here? Oh, she didn't say.
I said, uh, you know, hi, my
name's Joe. Nice to meet you.
And you know, she said Hi.
And she shook my hand
and he goes, no, no, no.
People get nervous when
they're around you. They've
seen you in fear factor. I go,
that is not nervousness. I go, this is
a crazy person. I'm telling you, Bro,
you're dating a crazy girl. It turned
out the whole time he was dating her,
he had no idea she was a meth addict,
like a severe metastatic.
And she also had like some boyfriend
who was like an ex boyfriend is still
picture to while she was
living at Brian's playing,
she was like hooking up with this
guy to get math craziness. So anyway,
Brian gets rid of her long, drawn out,
tries to save her, can't do it. I mean,
just a devastating shit.
Him. He would always,
he would always get himself hooked
up with these really crazy bitches.
It's when I was, when I met
him, when he was really young,
he was like trying to fix himself
through fixing other people.
It was very strange.
He got over it.
But the point is years
later he's walking by.
Remember that bar that Stan hope used
to go to the cat and the fiddle? Yeah.
You know, that's like a stripper or a
hooker walk right there. That's what,
what's his face? The English guy
got busted. What is his name? Grant.
Hugh grant got busted down there. I
was there. He picked up a hooker there.
It's grody. It's totally grody by the way.
That's my two year old's favorite word.
Grody grody. Anyway, um, uh,
so he's a walking to the cat and the
fiddle and as he's walking there,
he sees a hooker come his way and
he stops and he realizes it's his ex
girlfriend. Oh. And she's got
scabs on her face and shit.
They go get tested after. No, this is
years later and he looks at, it goes, uh,
hey, how you doing? She goes,
I sounded like you can guess
that was my life and accepted
it all. They said, wow,
that's all they said to each other.
And he,
he went into the bar and it was just like,
why the fuck the girl lived with him.
She lived with him, she was dating him
and now here she is with scabs. Anyway,
folks will be at Mandalay Bay, Mandalay
Bay theater, you worry forth. Um,
were we at, um, I want to be the
Ontario Improv tomorrow night.
It might be sold out.
It's a Korean Chad's show and I'm a
storyteller shell third in the pink,
purple onion and fourth February, third
year in La. Oh, there's another one.
February 3rd,
Jeff Garlin and powerful is that the
Improv lab improv back of the room.
They moved the regular room so it was
too big for that little fucking tiny ass.
But I'm doing my best to keep the
shows if $5, like I'm still trying to,
what are they trying to jack up the price.
What are they trying to make it 10
at least 10 tens not bad though.
It's reasonable. It's a
reasonable, reasonable, I think
that's all. It's all good.
They're good. They're very
entertaining shows. Yeah.
I liked the idea of keeping a cheap,
cause it's kind of experimental,
but it's a reasonable, I mean, they're
all very entertaining. It's well worth it.
Bert Kreischer. No burr Bill Burr a
boulevard. Yeah. Yeah. Bill bursal areas.
He's got great stories too. Um, so
anyway, February 4th Mandalay Bay theater.
February, January 28th, 29th
and 30th West Palm Beach Improv.
Brian, you can catch him at Sal's comedy
whole on Melrose all the time. Right?
What nights? Uh, I'm using their eye all
the time, but I'm hosting Sunday the 30th.
Oh No, I know, I guess
I'm not doing that now.
And the ladies he's looking for love.
Join my Twitter looking for love joins
Twitter. We're going to Australia. Sydney.
Oh yeah, we're going to
Sydney and I was saying, yeah,
we're doing something in Sydney. It'd be
nice. It was on my fucking Ustream page,
Brian, but it's not lat. Got
some old shit on here. Ann Arbor,
Michigan and Montreal.
Canada. It's on old.
Somebody put a link yesterday for the
tickets on every tweet. Yeah. Cool.
What are called Rudy Hill? That's the
name of the place. It's in Australia.
If you go on Joe rogan.net I
believe it has more information.
Are you going to have to use your brain?
And that's the only gay guy could get
in Australia. Cause these UFC things,
what happens is they book the
UFC like a couple of months out,
like three months out and say,
hey,
the UFC is going to be in Australia and
I immediately start looking for any more
big. But the problem is a lot of
these banned like these venues,
they book up with bands like six,
seven months in advance. So yeah,
so most of our taken,
so this is the place that I had to go to.
It's kind of a little bit further out,
but my friends in Sydney, I apologize.
We're going to have a good time to Ari.
Yeah,
we're going to fly over in
a fucking apartment. And
did you check out the plane?
We're going to really, oh, it's
the dopest shit ever. Quantis yeah,
it's fucking bad ass dude. Look a
little apartment and he's going to be,
we'll make videos. All right,
flashlight. All right. Dirty bitches.
If you go to Joe rogan.net,
you can get 15% off the flashlight,
click the link and enter in
the code name, Rogan. And uh,
are you still having used
one? Have, you know, you don't
want one, right? You scared.
Yeah, I'm scared. That's
exactly what it is to be honest.
It'd just be shooting loads
and thing all day and I'm like,
I don't need this in my life.
It's way better than beating off.
That's what it should say
in quotes on the bottom.
But it's way better than
beating off it is works. Okay.
That's the end of the show. Uh,
thank you very much Burt Christ.
You're supposed to be here tomorrow.
I haven't talked to him. Um,
you so hopefully we got it all.
I know he's traveling today.
Hopefully we got it all worked out,
but check Twitter and a,
you'll know for sure how I love
you bitches. I'll see you later.
This is your music. Yeah. What is it?
Don't make fun of. It's really good.
Is it a song? Yeah, it's called VCR.
Okay. This list guys and the commercial.
Tell me, Yo, live at so bad,
which you would digest me.
Get Sas.
Do you need to go to a doctor?
Hey Ben,
it's bad.
Thanks to Jeff Banks who
needs medical science,
doc Ninja kick its ass.
Your razor still stu syrup.
It still sucks.
It just fails miserably.
Gout Ninja kick its ass.
You get it.
You got a real problem,
dude.
Where's that one you had that
one song you made with your xx.
Brian's terrifying
humanity has ever produced.
You have a worm in your brain.
Niches picked no ass southbound.
Celebrate job knowledge. A beats on honor.
T mobo kicked our ass that much too,
so I can drive back to 1985
don't need nothing fancy.
I won't go too far. I just need, I'm fine
to
row somewhere making this,
they're going to make this the features
on their myspace page. I got an answer.
Call me. I'm story. Random words
in are fairly arriving ejaculators
it's called word salad. All
circuits are busy now. Right?
What does that song that you made with
your ex, can you make a song with your ex?
Yeah. What's that one about? It was
kind of a good one. What was it?
What was it about? Well, there's
the one that I'm punching the dog.
Is that what the one you're talking about
now? But it was good. It was fun. Uh Oh,
Juno Ish. Juno Ish. Yeah. That's
actually just a remake of a song. Oh,
don't do that because you don't have
rights. But there was the other one.
The other ones, the punching the
dog was about punching my dog.
Do you think that's funny man?
Yeah.
I just, your dog a douchebag
and no, this was, uh, because
if the song was about, um, her dog, how
she asked her dogs, she's from Texas,
I'm going to punch you. And I'm like,
you didn't say you're going to punch it.
So then I wrote this song and it was
a little dog too, right? I have a few.
Didn't really like punch it or anything.
Sometimes you have to punch
dogs. Yeah. Yeah. You know,
if they're trying to bite you,
punch him punching. Who's scared?
Let the dog know. Biting me,
mother fucker be repercussions.
You got punched in the face and you
get punched in the face that this is
actually a horse out and bite your hands
off. This is the punching. Go throw it.
Throw it. All right. You know, play. That
one is good or should we not play it?
Maybe we should all not good.
They're all my stupid song right now.
I don't want to leave people disappointed.
Okay, we're not going to work.
I wish I could've heard it. They're
going to think it's better than it was.
They're going to leave now thinking
that I missed out on something good.
Would reality folks,
is it shut off your iPhone?
Shut off.
Disconnect from use dreams.
Please don't listen to what we're doing
here right now for you to waste your
time. This is right. You craft
a rock clicking on the link.
Okay. Stop Tab. This is
worse than the other one.
This is where it pulled up,
man. Shut up. Please stop it
like a along with your own song.
This terrible bro like it. No. Well, I
could play the Jewish song. Nope. Nope.
That's no copyright. That's actually
really good. They were good.
That's really good. That's
it. That's a wrap, right?
Because you have to show a very
nice, thank you for having me, sir.
Thank you for being here, sir. This
was fun. Thanks for the ride, Brian.
Thanks everybody. Fall our
ship. You're on Twitter. S h.
O.
F. F. I. R. A. R. I. S. H. A.
F. F. I. R. R is your fear and
red band. Red Ban, but Brian,
what are you up to now? How many got, what
do you got? How many people you got now?
Like 11,000 or something like that.
11,000 people listening to your stuff.
You're happy with that man? No, I
need to beat the fucking sludge. Oh,
what is the sluts number?
21,000 how many did she
grow while she was with you?
I don't know. How much is it responsible?
Are you responsible for sure.
Growth made it more popular thing.
I definitely got her some.
He ain't got it from the
Internet. People different. Yeah.
Different people with her animated gifs
of her fingering herself all over the
website. How weird is that when this
competition? Brilliant. How weird is that?
Weird it ever went to
competition in this country.
What you gotta do to start that over
with? Start showing my dick. Okay.
Always tell the, hey, that's the end of
the show folks. Thank you very much. Bye.
We love you bitches.
Shut that fucking music off. Yeah. Yeah.